come on let's go
get out pick it up come on
let's go
now
oh
yes
jesus there's more oh my god this is insane
yeah baby that's what i've been waiting
for that's what it's all about magic time
oh
and we are back for the final weekend
of pogchamps 3 presented by grip6
alongside me the everyone's favorite
international master levy rosman danny we mesh
i just looked over i didn't know what shirt you
were wearing we're not i like i don't have a green
pawn though i need is that new merch i'm gonna get
you one of these so this was our meetup shirt from
this year because we didn't actually get to have
a meetup due to covid oh wait am i allowed to say
that word oh man we are start off on the wrong
foot anyway uh what we've got is a couple of
isolated pawns because everyone has felt isolated
but we put on chessboard it's very symbolic so
i'm gonna get you a shirt i've actually got like
five extra upstairs in the office i'm gonna get
your get your addi and ship you one real quick
so anyway how you doing man are you pumped to be
here this is how many how many jokes can we make
today that you don't need a gm for a chess show
uh a lot you know uh i i'll say this danny i'm
gonna say like i people people get hype when
whenever i'm doing commentary but i always defer
to you and i'm always kind of like everything
that i've ever done commentary wise has been
molded by danny wrench so it's crazy to be
alongside you because now i i you're the you're
like the color commentator like i gotta i you know
i feel like i'm sort of with like the mentor the
the idol for this job it's it's weird because um
that means the world to me i appreciate that
you're that you're the i'm gonna drive today
you're gonna be the chess expert but jokes
aside we know uh we we love working with all
our hosts but levy and i don't get to host
that often so we're gonna have a blast today
let's dive in remind everybody of the show man
we got a format that is started in groups the
players get to play round robins but it's all
about coming into the bracket stage where both
the consolation and championship brackets will get
us down to a winner single elimination is what it
is the same time control you know and love ten
minutes plus five second increment and then the
tiebreakers and we did have an epic tiebreaker
yesterday that that had the uh the chess world
and the streaming world of buzzing between
ludwig and sardosh it's five minutes per side
um and the finals of course of the of both the
consolation and the championship brackets will
take place tomorrow february 28th levy big prizes
right we doubled the prizes this time 100 100 000.
we're only taking some of that out of what we're
paying you to do commentary you're good with that
i i am good with that i was not expecting it to to
take that direction uh but uh no so these are uh
dude these are amazing prizes
you know um for for anybody
that that tunes in at the beginning of the
show and not in the uh the first or the or the
second hour it's kind of insane because twenty
thousand dollars for first place dude that's
like grand masters don't get that for winning the
world open which was historically the biggest open
you know prize fun tournament in the united states
so it's awesome it's true and nelly yeah there's a
lot of a lot of eyeballs on this event too and
while some of the players in this event maybe
wouldn't have ever thought of it that way but they
are some of the most watched chess players of all
time and some of the most handsomely rewarded
chess players of all time and it's a lot of fun
speaking of handsome rewards the community came
in clutch yesterday levy i would love to get to
another another epic goal today with the two
of us driving the show it's it's every dime
counts everyone it does go to charity and every
dime is matched by chess.com so can we can we at
least get over 30 today maybe get close to that 35
000 marker let's find out let's find out together
all right and before we dive in one more moment
to uh thank our first sponsor of the day gaia ki
of course they are our official regenerative yerba
mate and they're celebrating 25 years make sure
you spam the gaia key emote in the chat for your
chance to win a case um we do have a lot in the
office levy did you get your your case at gaia key
yet but yeah i did i've been i've been enjoying
sipping on that orange essence i think it's called
so yeah i've got i've got i've got classic gold
in front of me here and i've also got a cue coming
in from my producer that it's time for us to take
our first break the players aren't quite set
yet so we're going to take a very quick break
don't go anywhere when we return more specific
previewing and the actual games going down
between rayne wilson and benji fishy pogchamps
3 presented by grip six reach deep into yerba
mate culture and you'll discover people have long
gathered to imbibe mate to awaken the mind perform
extraordinary feats and exchange confidences
brewed from the naturally caffeinated and
nourishing leaves of the species of holly native
to the south american atlantic rainforest come to
life with guayaqui's wide assortment of yerba mate
offerings all with powers to unite and energize
subscribe to one channel free
i'm bj minton the founder of grip six when i
was 14 my very first job was a janitor at an
elementary school and i saved up my money and
one of the first things i bought was a wooden
chessboard from the mall i love chess chess
is challenging chess is thinking ahead it's
planning it's problem solving it's very similar
in manufacturing because in manufacturing
it's nothing but problems but problems are what
stimulate your brain problems are the things
that actually push you into creating new things
new technology better products things like that
at grip6 we make belts wallets and
socks we guarantee them for life
and just like chest they'll be around
forever
i love that first of all just want to say from
the founder and out of everything at one point
over there at grip6 the guy started himself of
course and uh everything about grip six is an
extension of him and they are awesome i'm fiddling
with my chest wallet in front of me right now but
i gotta remind all of you that you can go get a
chess themed wallet they are a special back order
they sold out but if you go to go.just.comgrip6
use the code pogchamps20 you not only can get 20
off but you can sign yourself up for a order they
are going to make a limited quantity to catch up
uh with the with the high demand that they
received for the wallets of course you can
also get belts wool socks which again i'm wearing
some right now i actually have that exact pair
that you see on that image it's kind of the neon
green they feel super comfy so um i've got anyway
yeah i love you go ahead nice i got the i got
the low-cut red ones i'm a little bit ashamed
to admit you know in these quarantine times
how how long you can leave socks on your feet
and not change them they were very comfortable
you know they were so comfortable with that hey
don't ever be ashamed to admit that i mean i you
know it's uh business up top party down low that
is the life of a streamer all right here we
go let's preview these matches we've got rain
wilson versus benji fishy uh this is um this is
the the last matchup that will decide who plays
sardoche in the championship and so regardless
of the fact that i think sardosh is the favorite
no matter who he faces i this is a coin flip
today right obviously those who who've been
paying attention know that i've been working with
rain we know benji's been working super hard with
young love big hammer norwegian grandmaster but
i you know i i told reign i think i think uh him
and benji are two of the best players uh
left and i have no idea what's gonna happen
yeah totally and basically the way it seems
right now is that uh sadosh benji and and and
rain are obviously uh the three strongest but to
be honest like it it really felt like a comeback
story by by ludwig yesterday uh he he played
he played unbelievable i was hype i've never
been as hyped as i was yesterday watching that
match it was like the whole you know uh pre-show
hype with the music and then the storytelling
love's got a very you know compelling way to keep
your attention so that was sick i wish he had held
it together a little bit more under the you know
under the pressure of the blitz game but um how
was your did you do any prep with uh with rain for
for benji uh we did we did i'm not gonna get into
it yet because obviously we'll see what happens
on the board but we um you know obviously i'm a
big believer in the prep being focused on focus
on what you do best don't try to change things
at the last minute because we know how often
that can actually backfire i think unless your
opponent has revealed like some obvious weakness
right then then really it's just about improving
your openings improving your approach to things
so that you're in the best space possible speaking
of being the best space possible i think the games
are starting in fact looks like they have and
we're off to see the wizard with a french and we
did look at this full disclosure because benji for
the record has pretty much only played a french
in in his uh in his chess career and so brain
and i spent some time just looking at the basics
of the advanced variation no trickery
and you're gonna see that on the board
yeah advance is uh it's a hot subject of debate
because i remember way back when i told hikaro
i don't think that this is like the best way for
white to try to you know get a french player out
of their comfort zone but but to be honest if
you prepare like the miller berry with bishop
to d3 which is very tricky right uh i don't
know okay so you you is this is this still uh
man i guess i'm just gonna have to talk
about it because it's happening i did
not expect this to happen necessarily because
benji has also played some different stuff um
but this is the mainland french and i well
i agree with you i initially tried to get
rain to play my own knight to c3 which is
move three knight to c3 for those wondering
but ultimately he felt really comfortable with
the structure and he feels like that's the one
thing that he feels kind of confident about is
getting that structure and so um you know we
worked through the basic of the advanced ideas we
talked about playing a3 so that you could get b4
and we see that benji has actually not
stopped that so we'll see if rain plays b4
which is what we looked at and and i hope
that he follows through with kind of the idea
you know i i'm not going to see this is no don
your profit here when i coach my students i'm
not looking for a check mate and six moves all due
respect to the profit right i'm just like hey man
this is what you're doing in this structure this
is where your pieces belong you're a good player
this is the middle game ideas you'll get and
go for it the craziest thing about benji is
that he's had his chess.com account since 2018. in
january of this year january 10th his rapid rating
was 817 he has gained 545 points he is currently
at his peak which he hit yesterday so this kid
and that's insane danny like 100 percent and and
he's been growing i mean hammer's been tweeting
about it they've been playing practice games
right training games um so he is he is all in
and when we first invited benji because of the
fortnight conflict he had he was he was that he
really wanted him but he wasn't sure he could get
it not only has he played in pogchamps but he's
maybe going to knock on the door to getting in
the final against sardoche so we are officially
in original territory in terms of our prep just
so the cat is out of the bag danny working with
rayne wilson i i talked to him about playing b4 if
given the opportunity and that that would be the
best way to relieve the pressure on the queen side
he's kind of mixed up the line a little bit here
with this bishop d3 but obviously it's still okay
white is still in a in a good space but the reason
i taught him b4 levy is because now you can't play
bishop e3 because queen takes b2 so he's kind of
forced to part ways with the light square bishop
which is really not ideal to be fair though benji
also took on d4 early which is also not ideal
because it's giving rain this move knight to c3
yeah exactly that's actually the like the the the
deep meta of of all of this opening is that white
waits to move the b1 knight wants to put it on c3
i'm drawing arrows on my own board because i'm so
used to it but uh yeah and actually rain does rain
know this idea from your training or does he just
realize that snapping that knight is just nice
because now you're gonna play knight c3 and hit
d5 i think he knows he messed up because in theory
he kind of didn't have a choice i mean okay you
can play the gambit lines but the move order he
played there's no way to defend the d-pawn other
than taking here right that yeah that's fair
right because bishop e3 okay now he goes b4 so
i guess the the real issue is that white trades
the light squared bishop and has six pawns out
of seven on the wrong color square you've got a
dark squared bishop left but all your pawns are
on dark squares so still computer is like trying
to say white has some advantage and that basically
rests in the fact that black has those two bishops
but the position is very closed so yeah yeah and
one of the things probably benji should have done
instead of castles to take advantage of the way
rain played it is to play try to play move like
a5 in some of these positions where your your
goal is to pry open and kind of target the queen
side especially with white's inability to play b5
you can sometimes do with a bishop on d3 so so
i think um the question will be interesting as
to whether benji understands this a5 idea have him
and hammer talked about that that's a key point in
undermining the front structure did they not get
around to that because they didn't necessarily
expect a3 i think that's going to be a key thing
in this position and we see he kind of doesn't
and he's actually blundered the d5 pawn so this
is not working out well for benji no it's not
and uh okay i mean the truth is that after knight
takes d5 e7 is still protected so computer is
giving like plus four something completely
ridiculous because it's got a very kind of
methodical way now to pick apart everything and
win but rain's got to see through everything
like he's gotta realize that taking on e7 is
good and then he's gotta realize like the next
step it's not just winning a pawn it's that
black's position is gonna crumble right but
i i think he kind of got lucky the bench he just
didn't play bishop e6 there right um but but okay
he's gotten the d5 pawn and now he should be in
control uh speaking of uh speaking of in control
the community continuing to guide us they're
steering us toward this thirty thousand maybe
thirty five thousand peter kkg ij just donated 100
bucks and we've had some other smaller donations
too so thank you so much hoping to reach our goals
yet again for uh the second day in a row all right
man i and i know i don't know how you feel i know
that anna gets super nervous with her students i
know that you know just different coaches and
different personalities when i'm here i legit
feel zero pressure like maybe that's because i'm
detached maybe it's because i have four kids so
i don't really care what rayne does you know i
don't know you know he he he doesn't listen to
me half the time in the lessons anyway so um you
know i mean i'm just gonna be honest and if he's
gonna trash me no i'm kidding he he's great but i
i levy jokes aside do you feel pressure when your
students are playing that they do what you did or
are you kind of emotionally unattached it's it's
been a while right so before i was well even when
i was streaming i i ran a scholastic chess program
uh for those that don't know and i think i felt
that pressure for a kid that was like a good kid
like a kid that you know works hard like i want
them to do well not like brady wilson not a good
kid well yeah like i had those students that like
wouldn't pay attention bless him so like you know
i had a kid the last round of states like we were
in the running for sure i was nervous in those
moments for sure yeah no no no no no no so there's
a plot twist so this kid is like he's like not a
very nice kid like you know very you know pompous
kid whatever comes back made it in eight moves
and i remember looking at him and being
like well shouldn't they talk [ __ ]
like you know alex in that moment
i was like how do i counterbalance
my desire to be a good one please clip that
that is the best chess coach advice to your
kid losing a big game flip that and ship
that for levy rosman please on twitter okay
rookie will play by rain great move and obviously
regardless of our discussion on the opening prep
brain didn't quite get what i work with him on but
clearly i think benji struggled with the advanced
line anyway uh not knowing kind of the a5 idea
so in the end you know let you know benji's big
mistake of taking too early on d4 is a good lesson
for french players because that's really what
leads to the advantage ring got here with knight
c3 and the d5 plunge so this has got you know
benji's got to work his way out of this i'm with
levy it's not as clear of a win as the eval bar
would make you think um after that move it might
be although after that move if you take c7 you've
got d5 we got forking problems on the d file we
also have taking f6 oh this is gonna get spicy
yeah this is the oh okay see the problem well
you know that's a great move uh but benji's gotta
find bishop d5 like it's a great move unless
you play bishop d5 you gotta plug the square
right yeah good point because this is not yeah go
ahead sorry i was gonna say bishop yeah bishop f7
e6 d5 i mean black resigns black forget black
stops playing the french defense after two f7
so i did tell i did tell rain that i said
my main goal is for you to get hammer
to feel like he needs to switch his students
openings like that's the main goal and he's like
who's hammer like don't worry about it yeah that
i always wonder you know in these events like how
many of these creators know each other like not
even by name you know just by my content all this
stuff because they're they're all over they're all
working you know maybe even hundreds of hours in
a seven day week i'm just curious like you know
do people listen to logic's music but put that
you know and then like you know do they watch mr
b's videos there's so many different people across
so many different uh kind of categories but you
know back to the chess uh this is uh looking like
your guy is going to win the game because falling
apart um well it is one of the funny things about
having having rain in the event because he's i
mean the dude's dwight schrute right i mean yeah
he's he's maybe maybe the name reign wilson isn't
trending in the same way that you know mr beast
or pokeman is but we know the office is still the
most watched show netflix said so and um if you if
you google how can i watch the office you would
be following a google trend because most people
freaked out when that content is officially on
peacock by the way i'm subscribing to peacock
pretty much for the office i don't i don't know
about that that peacock is an animal with a fancy
tail the new mbc streaming service everyone's
goal these days is to shut down content lock
it down so that we all have 75 subscriptions
we have to make are you allowed to promote
another streaming way on a streaming website yeah
not oh man we'll cut it out of the youtube vodka
oh you know i'll add it to the list of streaming
platforms i shouldn't be mentioning a lot mixer
okay wait if i go to google and and
i type in peacock am i gonna do it
am i oh okay that's just an
animal it's just okay um anyway
rain rain is definitely cleaning up here
so tough lesson for benji i think that um
rain again didn't get what we looked at but the
the goal i took as a coach ate off because i was
like look man always what happens here is most
the time you look at these specific x's and o's
he plays a move order one of you forgets it focus
on the forest through the trees what are you doing
here and that's really legit is my mindset and i
think it's partly because you just have had i've
had so many experiences where when you try to
go the other way and buckle down and say this
is the exact trap the amount of times you get what
happened between charlie and xqc levy is like one
in a million right it just never works out that
way so you should focus on your bigger chess goals
rather than trying to trap people all right i'll
get off my soapbox about coaching all right here
we go yeah and that was that you know that was
a that was a point of like contention right
uh because on the one hand you want your you want
your student to win speaking of which like that
story of the kid losing in eight moves that was an
opening trap you know and like sometimes you lose
in an online three-minute game sometimes he was
in the last round of the state championship like
right it happens to everybody yeah yeah exactly
i've been caught i remember i was there was there
was a day i was streaming i was like on a roll
and then a guy gave me a piece in the open i'm
like what is this i got mated a few moves later
and and it was a trap i got trapped like i thought
i knew the traps all the traps i got trapped queen
sack from mate like the most nasty trap i've ever
seen so you can learn something new every day
even if you get you know clowned on stream so
well the only thing that could go wrong
here now is reign missing back rank
so it's on the board um as a god mature
would say on the board will he stop checkmate
yeah i i think that at this level he will
i mean i i just these are the final few
participants of the event queenie one is a very
there it is nice bishop v2 i don't like that he
hasn't created a fort for his king but i don't
i also don't think he's gonna hang backrank mate
yeah no i don't i don't think he will either by
the way brain was very proud of the hat that he
bought he showed me in last night's lesson um
he said if he started to lose he was gonna he
was gonna rip off his shirt and just like focus on
just the hat on the screen like try to intimidate
the kid he asked me if he thought if i thought
that would intimidate his opponent i said no
well danny it's like it's like a speech
championship right like we pan to any gm and
it's just this right like we call it the fabicam
the forehead cam yeah exactly that's that that's
you guys watch any gm on camera that's what
they're they're under the screen it's amazing
and you've been a part of those tech sessions it's
always so funny because we're like all right are
you sure this is where you're gonna be when you're
playing yep all right can you move around a little
bit for me show me how you're gonna be yep this
is where i'm gonna be the moment the first game
starts i'm completely out of frame it's like oh
dear god here we go again i think that a lot of
them have gotten better because of the online
experience but it is it is funny uh okay wow
and look at that it's a great move by rayne i
think even though it wasn't necessary i think
he saw that the rook was pinned right and so he's
getting the queen out of the way preparing to take
he's in great shape yes i think part of our
getting distracted here is the fact that
within 15 moves uh white is up a rook this is the
last thing that i expected i'm not gonna lie but
that's what happens when opening meltdowns
happen and um well really it was it was one
it was just one blunder right if we go it was
knight takes d5 because if you play bishop e6
you know black is i mean like you you i
think you said it well levy you said the
computer still thinks it's equal but we were
already talking about black has the bishop pair
talking about a5 i mean i personally i i don't
know i feel like the long-term features of this
position could be better for black because of that
but it's sometimes you make a blunder and we had
this yesterday me and hicari like you you make a
blunder and then it's like it's like everything
falls apart it was the it was the worst blunder
you could make for the position and then this move
is so there you go that's what happened welcome
everyone on chance three presented by grip6 hey
uh so your move order if you if you take this back
to um to move to move six so you combined knight
f3 with a3 this idea to expand let's i want to i
want to stay here just to make sure benji doesn't
blunder mate and then we're going to go back and
answer that fair because i guess i actually don't
know that i have the answer you want i don't
know that i'm a i'm a french advanced expert i
don't my line is nice e3 but i'll tell you what i
what i taught rain full disclosure no no i i was
okay he he doesn't hang mate no i was just going
to say that what you taught reign took benji uh
yeah normally a3 is the move if
you're gonna play it in this order
yes and so what i was going to say i checked his
games i went to opening tree and like i checked
benji's games the way you taught rain to play
coincidentally benji's only seen two times out
of like 70 games ever so he wasn't prepared for
this he reacted wrong and at this level when
you react wrong it can snowball you don't feel
confident you don't find the right ideas dude
it was hilarious about this this only
happened because i don't know the line well
like i literally was just teaching him
dude you just develop and play a3 i didn't
even think about the move order wow look at
that ipad right there genius yeah let's uh
all right i uh i feel kind of bad um i feel kind
of bad because this is just going to be a long
conversion process now now white's going to trade
the queen benji's probably going to play queen g6
but it's it's you know reigns going to win and i
would be great baseball commentators because we've
been commenting on a lopsided game for a while
and and i'm having a good time oh it's great
i think i think the truth is that like we know the
result at this level i mean unless rain just does
something catastrophic so we could talk about
we thought about anything i mean that's super
flower seeds isn't that a big and he still hasn't
freed his back rank so i mean yeah blunders happen
i don't know i mean we did see a completely
insane rain wilson in the second game against
moist critical like that was that was
a but this at this point you're up
three minutes chill out trade the pieces don't
lose anything don't hang mate you'll be fine
we know five there you go um shout out to the
uh community and the viewership we're growing
here the day's just getting started very good
okay this is an awesome battery set up by benji
and again this is the what you would
love to see that is that is the most
tight rope walking way to stop that mate danny
you took the words out of my mind i was about
to say what you'd love to see what you'd love
to see right bishop c3 is the move that's like
dude solve the problem yeah i mean like g3 we
don't even we go to break like we don't really
okay just like just root d8 the rook is gone no
more back rank problems if frank wilson hangs
back ranked mate i'll i don't know i'll give like
500. oh my god that movie just played i wasn't
expecting it my calves my calf muscles tightened
i don't even know i have calf muscles danny i go
for a two-minute walk and i get how do you still
work out in quarantine you still work dude i'm
obsessed with crossfit it's my only therapy um but
the gym i go to totally socially distance and safe
what is going on here um everyone gets their own
box and it's like it's it's away from other people
it's very very cleanly we have to wipe down
all the weights when we're done it's actually
kind of gross the amount of uh clorox that
goes into keeping that place covered free
i might be getting sick because of that but
that's a whole other story oh queen c now rook
d7 right rain's done messing around i mean
rain is uh he sees rook d7 we're shipping it
yeah or queen d7 but yeah rook d7 man ranges no
back rank yeah there it is all right he smoked
this one that's he really did that was that was
actually stunning you know i i i think that benji
is a little bit more solid with white he does his
whole ready with d4 you got prep against that too
uh we didn't look at d4 i
thought he played knight f3
uh yeah he plays like knight f3 then he delays
then he plays but what rayne does mostly is is
a king's indian setup that's you've seen his
games he plays the d6 stuff is black where he
got in big trouble against charlie that um you
know the he plays like a pierce kind of thing
that's what rayne does so he's his plan is
pretty much he's got one trick up his sleeve
he's going to go for it if not i told him go
back to your thing so we'll see what happens
i mean i would love to i'd love to be in depth and
analyze the position but i i actually one thing i
just want to point out i don't want rain to take
all the pawns i actually really respect what
sartosh does when he's winning like he just he
just goes for the kill like he doesn't care about
the other pieces and like you know no g3 just
queenie's like queen f7 bishop d2 done clean cut
game is over so why or why i think sardosh and i
think you would agree or and i were talking today
like that as well as the fact that he tends to
play better when he plays faster his intuition
is so strong like the fact that he sometimes
you can't measure that players of all levels
blunder but certainly we know that there's a
lot of blunders in pogchamps um but the fact
that he when he wins he just cleans up and the
fact that he um oh speaking of he plays better
yeah that that really was brutal that's not quite
a game that will make you quit the french defense
but it will definitely make you reconsider
what to play against the advanced french
uh because yeah that that that game if anything
anybody in the chat who plays e4 and struggles
with the french that was a game to watch right
there that was that was very convincing great
okay well that was uh that was a a very quick win
for rayne wilson but we still have a lot of chess
ahead if you're just tuning in don't go anywhere
we've got game two coming up between rayne wilson
and benji fishy to decide who joined sardoche in
the championship bracket and then of course nico
and tubo will round out the consolation bracket
later today me and levy rosman will be right back
enjoy hikaru with the break it's pog champs
three presented by grip six well let's take
a look i i know you i'm almost certain you're
debating me but i'm gonna i'm gonna look anyway
but i'm gonna i'm gonna look anyway oh
wait no let's go back to puzzle rush
sorry i have to go back to puzzles um so
let's keep going with puzzles one sec oh
wait no let's go back to puzzle rush
sorry i have to go back to puzzles um
okay let's let's go back here all right
let's keep rolling okay but i don't know if
this morning i got a request from a streamer
known as ludwig on discord for a bot v
bot so he can pair his bot i.e ludwig versus bots
like mr beast you down for that feature i started
a conversation in slack with the project team
the product team from computer that sounds like
a cool feature what do you think i'm i'm down
for that it sounds great it's more apparent
versus wrench and you see what the bots do i
there was a there was someone i saw something on
twitter somewhere somebody may have made a chess
streamer tournament like i bought a bot streamer
yeah yeah yeah that was smarter chefs are uh the
stats guy he has chessgoals.com which is a great
site go to chess girls.com there you go and i
think in the first round i played uh i played
andrea botes and uh i won but it was uh it was
intense oh i didn't win i bought it i mean frankly
you know danny i get i get dms from people who are
like why did your bot play h6 on move one like i
don't know i didn't program it sorry my butt my
butt is literally the punch line of thing although
i made a joke a few streams ago when i see someone
like with like an 1100 rating posting that they
beat the daniel wrench bot do i even need to
fill in the blank in terms of what they did
like i mean i love you but yeah um
well there there's this guy who uh
exploited the feature where if if you don't
refresh the page the bot plays the same moves
oh so this kid yeah this kid jack uh he he made
a video where he pre-moved like 70 straight moves
or something and then he beat my butt and then
he like recorded my reaction made a big thing
out of it that is hilarious okay so this is
not quite what we looked at this is already a
transposition note that benji played knight f3
d5 and d4 so we are we are reign is on his own
i absolve myself of all influence over the game
but i did tell him this that if we get a queen
spawn okay he remembered that that's awesome you
got to make sure in a queens pawn game everybody
that you can take back with a pawn because you've
got to keep that structure together you don't want
things like this to happen or your opponent has
two pawns in the center you don't this is actually
theory but we're not going to get into that the
point is positionally you've really got to protect
so i'm glad to see rayne remember that principle
he will probably play g6 here nope he didn't g6
and bishop back is is kind of what he's familiar
with king's indian stuff so here we go we'll see
yeah he gets the bishop outside the pawn chain
so i guess he wanted to play e6 now this is not
like great but if black plays e6 it's extremely
solid okay he goes g6 he's playing this like gotta
komski like the schlectherslaw variation except he
doesn't have a score admission i'm gonna shorten
that last hundred dollar donor named to t bird um
although i guess i can say turd bird my kids will
probably think it's funny hey turd bird turd bird
just donated a hundred bucks way to go turtle bird
of all the things all the things that get set
on the pogchamps broadcast i'm pretty sure
turd is uh i'm pretty sure it's legal yeah we'll
be fine so rayne played bishop g4 and takes up
three this is obviously um not a but what i'll
do is i'll say the one line we kind of looked at
is he he wanted to have an idea against the king's
name that if he could he would play something like
this levy and and and basically play bishop g4
and try to play queen d7 in here and i think again
you know we were looking at a specific line that's
away from his structure and i said like very
unlikely you'll get this so remember you know if
and when you transpose go to positions play for
structures you're familiar with because you'll
be more familiar with the tactics and the ideas
and so he did kind of ultimately do a little bit
of both here right he played bishop g4 which isn't
super common but g6 is obviously very solid and
now black is in you know this is a very equal game
yeah if if he remembers kind of the ideas of the
king's indian which is in many positions to play
the move e5 you know he can set that up but i
think really the best move here for black is is
yeah that and now you know black says i've traded
my light squad bishop but i have all these pawns
on the light squares i'll just play a6 and then
like you know i'll complete the mythical quest
of all pawns on light squares uh but benji
is really good at these positions he likes b3
bishop b2 slow development and then later expand
with e4 he's in his wheelhouse so okay and as i
say that he plays that move so i think this shows
he has the plan that you're talking about living
he's aware that he needs to strive for e4 i'm
with you he needs to complete development first
benji you got to develop and maybe even
put rooks in the center first don't
don't be in a rush to play e4 um right
but but i think he has that idea in mind
well i think bishop d3 was a really important loss
of tempo because yeah like there was no need to go
bishop d3 he should have just and now right now if
rain plays c5 man this is no you're right actually
that's right bad or positive i'm officially
rooting for benji in this game we want overtime
we want free chips we want pizza too i would
love some pizza i had pizza last night at 2 a.m
that's why i love new york city yeah that's
why i'm also gaining too much weight but
it was it was amazing man pepperoni right out
the right out the oven oh so good oh my god
rain rain's in his own today i can feel it yeah
you're seeing the board well e5 is a great move
benji i'm that one it's insane danny that
like i heard you say this to hikari yesterday
we're talking about one maneuver or one pawn move
in pog champs it's one move bishop d3 and all
of white's chances to get an advantage were gone
because he he coordinated his pieces the wrong way
no and it shows you know you're
following up on what mina carl
was saying it's it's it shows how far
we've come i mean these guys are all um
you know not to say that any of the players in
the beginning pog champs even if they were more
beginner level that it wasn't the same kind
of authentic everyone's trying to get better
at chess experience but it really does show that
you know when you have people going full half oo
and you got sardosh on the grind right and
then you've got players like rain wilson and
benji fishy i think from the very beginning benji
rayne and sardosh have clearly been the top guys
by the way taking d5 was a really good response
by benji this is not going to be that clear at all
yeah so you don't need to take what just got
moved because then you would have gotten your
queen and bishop forks which is the whole
reason bishop d3 was such a problem is that
you don't you didn't need to make that move
your bishop was not really changing too much
you know what the computer is suggesting here
c5 by black which just looks like a mouse lip
that's the best move and then it wants knight
a4 and that's why is so deceiving get ready
for this eval bar to go nuts everybody because i
don't think see and here you go rain plays queen
e7 so as soon as we were plotting e5 and
i think it was rightfully so i think rain
is seeing the board well and he clearly saw
this idea but the truth is it may have been a
little bit of a too advanced follow-up because
now now he's going to get himself in trouble
yeah d take c6 now benji's got to get that
tunnel vision i benji's got to realize e4
is not a threat which i think is why he played
bishop d3 he was so worried about the e4 square
but there's no threat like right you're fine just
take the pawn take the ball probably don't take
twice because a rook will come to c8 and hit the
night and maybe it works i haven't gone fully car
here and actually you know calculated but now
rain is now rain is going off the deep end here
oh man rain's gone wild i think they both had
just miscalculated the pieces on that square
yeah that's it and the problem is
that now black is down three pawns
just like that i mean okay so bishop d3 was genius
i mean what was it you said at the break you said
benji's much more solid as white even if he made
the small step there i think that this is um
okay brain was down almost a rook against charlie
right and came back in drew to hold his match
so you know i think he's i think he's a
stronger player and he shouldn't give up
but i think more than likely this is
looking like benji's game right now
yeah now reigns well he's got to take the bishop
but i think that at that point benji's probably
going to take with the queen just like you know
right off his instinct is yes trade the queen
i'm up pawns um what you showed earlier
like if we go back before reign played e4
yeah uh although now he takes on c6 so he's uh
it's a it's a avalanche now getting in trouble
but yeah it takes i think takes could have been
met by this but yeah peter says white's fine
here i don't even know i think knight d5 yeah
that's it yeah but maybe well i was gonna say
maybe rain saw that but clearly that was not his
ideas idea was that e4 and that was sadly a bad
idea and sometimes in chess bad ideas result in a
lot of loss and in this case it's a lot of pawns
yeah still tricky obviously obviously black's
in big trouble the other thing he's also down
on time so one thing you got to give kudos to
benji is like that first game that first game
was bad right he got he got his butt kicked in
the french but but the mindset he comes back with
here i mean he's he's playing fast he's playing
confident it shows that he's not rattled and so um
yeah i think it's it's it's important for a guy
like benji like when you lose a game like that
you're just like what did i do wrong oh i made
that one wrong pawn capture in the in the opening
okay let's go next time i know what i'm supposed
to do so that's it memory loss oh it's so useful
in chess except i still remember i know dumb moves
i play football like well and maybe you're maybe
i i shouldn't say that maybe you're like no danny
we're nothing alike but what i'll say is i i'm
definitely a streaky player so the problem
with that is like when things are going well
they can go really well right but when you
can't let go of mistakes a lot of the times
you know you go and you go into those like
you're playing against the ghosts of your past
right and and so it's easier said
than done but i do think all the great
all the great white says that all the
great white sharks right in any sport
have short-term memory loss you know and they they
just smell blood in the water they don't remember
their mistakes and that's what they do i read
that term in a book called talent is overrated
great book and he talks about the great white
shark mentality and his short-term memory loss
yeah i uh i should probably like buy that book
who's the author i love the title because i'm
like oh talent is overrated that means i have a
chance that's what yeah that's what i'm saying
who's the author i'm gonna look this uh i've
already googled enough things by the way a4 is a
wonderful move bishop a3 is a wonderful move yeah
it not only threatens a5 it threatens bishop a3
what a weird match i mean this could be
like two games of just lopsided chess here
yeah a4 is great what an amazing idea like
in a position full of pawns and bishops and
queen and knight he finds a pawn move
like see he wants to play three and
good kid man he's really good you
can play bishop b5 and save i mean
that's probably the best bishop b7 obviously
if you're if you're going if you're into that
kind of thing right if you're attacking brooks
on the back rank now some people are into that
that's a move yeah because
yeah it's definitely a move
definitely move the good thing is you're at
least defended so you don't really worry about
if the rook moves up and attacks you but yeah
for the most part you probably should avoid
very simple one move attacking moves that don't
do too much but in this case gets your bishop
out of the way or out of danger she don't go d5
i'm gonna d5 you lose the game with d5 maybe so
well the problem with d5 obviously if it trades
pieces but you know you don't want to create
but no d5 is not a bad move
at all right i mean it's a
way to get some pieces off the board it's uh
my concern was the a1 rook i don't want him
to open the diagonal just completely forget so
replays but should be five yeah queen takes b3
takes b3 action a little bit a little bit back in
the game you still got to worry about bishop a3
but at this point you just got to get some
material back so you should probably take and then
cross your fingers
it's two pawns up now i mean you know
it's still a game man because it's
white's advantage is in the fact that white is
up two pawns but it you don't feel it always
because the more pawns there that have been
traded the more open the lines are so you
right everything's open it's all open all all
over the place yeah you're right and these are
two pawns but they're also like you know they're
not the they're not the most dangerous pawns yet
you know you advance them up the board that's one
thing but they're not they're not like a two-pass
pawn advantage against nothing on the queen
side so this is going to take some coordination
gonna take some technique for benji for sure
in positions like this it's very often you you
don't yeah like you don't need to play a move like
that because now the queen just goes exactly back
to where it was and what have you done you kind
of put your rook on a weird square so or even
right queen b4 but yeah that would threaten rook
scene one i think that's a little bit advanced but
you're right this is you get yourself in trouble
when you start putting pieces on squares they
don't belong you know even if it's not a blunder
yet that stuff adds up comes back to bite you
as they say that stuff comes back with you not
everything stays in vegas okay i i wouldn't know
um only times i've ever been in vegas uh i played
chess there in uh 2019 yeah um yeah but i i i'm
i was just there like solo yeah i'm like i've been
i've spent more time in casinos for someone who
has never actually gambled i spend more time in
concedos maybe than any other human did you just
watch what were you like playing chess raised you
know chess tournaments you know on the west coast
you're going to vegas all the time you know yeah
one of my craziest vegas experiences is going to
sound like super like mild but um the millionaires
just end with a white tiger and you're at mike
tyson's house no no it ends with me you know i
was 19 my first nine with it with a knife yep no
joke i stayed at the travel lodge in vegas which
like you know all these resorts but i was like
a kid and i was like i'm going to go play a chess
tournament i want to save money so i walked every
day to planet hollywood and i had to walk through
the casino to make it to the yeah it was wild i
couldn't step off of the carpet you know what
i mean like on the casino if you step out yeah
you're uh in your lane kid you're not 21. um yep
yep okay by the way rain rain is avoiding trades
which this is a this is a good idea i think
conceptually when you're like i'm losing i
need to keep the pieces on the board but rook cd8
is actually a big mistake if benji sees bishop a3
because this rook here is running out of squares
um oh it looks like benji has played a5 and knight
b5 so that was that was a missed opportunity from
benji bishop a3 would have been pretty nice and
that's what the computer liked um rook c6 now
probably just to tag the queen but yeah white
is still better let's put it this way not too
much has changed and the time keeps ticking so
something's got to happen soon right and and now
benji is down on the clock so we were praising
him earlier for being in the right mindset
short-term memory loss you're up on the clock
oh yeah man that is a fancy move but very
unnecessary that's a move that gives a coach
a little bit of a you can if you listen closely
you can hear young lugma hammer squeezing his
teddy bear for comfort like if white's queen is
on g3 here that could have been a disaster because
the knights of three knights show the imaginary
tactic if the queen is here taking giving up your
queen and then taking e2 with a fork down
on the on the king and queen over here so
um would have been imagination of a camera i'm
sure you're lurking watching waiting judging
a lot like my wife just sitting there in the
shadows how's the teddy bear buddy tell me in chat
he's uh he he's been live and i think he's been
watching his uh his protege sorry everyone go
over to twitch.tv slash gmj's j l h give him a
follow yes did you just compare your your wife
to you ludwig camera i'm still like i was looking
for a follow-up i couldn't i couldn't think of one
i'm just i'm just making sure i heard that right
um who should be offended in that case probably
probably it's complicated right a lot like uh
amber's relationship status all right let's
let's listen into hammer actually it's kind of a
rare thing we can do so we're gonna we're gonna
cue him up and uh i don't know how long we'll be
able to stand this but let's see as long as we can
right benji gives away the bishop that
was his plan with the previous move
now dealing with the threat against his rook uh
fortunately he has a very nice way of dealing
with that because he can move his rook up and
then that rook is protected and it's protecting
this guy it's protected by that guy and
it's putting pressure against this guy
so benji has a now starting to find some harmony
with his pieces yeah i agree there you go camera's
a pretty good chess commentator yeah you know
i i think hammer is like the first person on
earth to pronounce every letter in every word
he just has like the way he he talks he just
every he just talks perfectly like i don't know he
has like a very perfect way right he doesn't you
know he's no person no he's just like very precise
like he just i want him to coach me on anything
how to assemble a piece of furniture i want him to
stand there and be like all right now you've got
for those who don't know and as sometimes we
say things in chat i understand chat you're
like you know don't ask us to understand
your inside jokes dandy so i get it i'm
not trying to defend but i'm you know we're
good i'm good friends with hammer and he's
actually very well known he may be the face of
commentary in norway for those who don't know
childhood friends with magnus carlsen uh
was actually his second when magnus won his
first world championship title and hammer does
commentary for tv2 uh in norway which is a a big
uh private uh broadcasting corporation and
they cover chess most people think of nrk
but um anyway so hammer is a fantastic chess
commentator jokes aside and he is worth a follow
if you want to do it um but okay this game is
coming back we do need to buckle up here we've got
two and a half minutes approaching for benji and
reign to his credit like he did against charlie uh
levy he was losing out of the opening but this is
still an absolute mess that is a really good move
super good because it was maybe the only way to
guard both pieces here you've got well there's
roo k2 but rook a2 is kind of a gross move like i
don't know it finds the equal danger and now yeah
that's super clutch very very clutch by
benchy now benji's competed in like massive
you know fortnite tournaments it's obviously not
the same chess is very uh slow-paced compared to
that but your time is constantly ticking
it's a very different type of adrenaline
the adrenaline's huge i mean rain was saying
last night he's like man i feel like i'm like
20 worse as a player when i play in front of so
many people he's like i know that surprised you
because i'm an actor but it's different like
when so many people are watching me live live
viewing is different than recording like oh yeah
you know what i mean and he was like saying like
i'm so nervous when i'm playing and i'm like dude
i understand and i said well if it makes you feel
any better you're playing in the most viewed
chess tournament of all time so no pressure
straight up by the way like that that that
that is amazing i um dare i not compare my
improv extracurricular activity freshman
year of college uh to you know dwight
like it's so it's so good you show up we showed
up for five hours every sunday to record 6 p.m
to 11 p.m it was on the west side manhattan you
show up you eat food you hang out you know you
talk a little banter with your your friends you
record stuff cut action this this this you're gone
like streaming's very different i mean in my in
the speech championship it's nerves man the heart
rate is up even when before you're playing so i
get it i totally get it well rain is keeping this
close benji now at two minutes and 20 seconds but
if the a5 pawn falls there it goes yeah this is
still still anyone's game and actually remember
all rain needs is a draw to punch his ticket to
the championship so we are all rooting for benji
we want overtime here but but the advantage has
slipped away you know if he finds an idea like 93
95 though right now now what he needs to do levy
is use the dynamic duo the queen and the knight
to create something against the king over here yes
the only two pieces that if you combine them hold
all the powers i mean they can't you know take uh
right they can't promote when they get to the end
but um he's gotta not fall behind too much on time
with our forces combined we are captain planet
that's a great move by the way he's headed to b7
that's such a good move such a good move and
he has king h2 so his king is always safe
yep that little forward no despite that apon
falling i feel like benji is he's in a he's
in a hard position to blunder right like look at
it everybody's protected he's got very um a very
good piece set meaning the pieces as levy said
they work well together and if he's got his eyes
on the prize of f7 i think this is going to be
super hard for rain i'm trying to predict what
rain is thinking like he obviously sees rook b7
i'm thinking he'll go rook d7 but then rook b8 and
now you have a whole new set of problems or will
he play like queen a6 or queen c7 just not letting
it but again you run into more problems queen c7
knight d5 so what is he going to do and he doesn't
even mean is like queen a2 and he doesn't find it
queen a2 would have been a move that like defends
wow but benji's backing up why didn't he play rook
b7 i think he'd be mentally prepared queenie too
i think at this point you start preparing moves
you're like if he does this i'm just snap off a
move because rook b7 of course yeah rook b7 would
have been better he was worried about queenie one
i think queenie one rook b7 but there's nothing
there right checks checks are for kids right
you gotta remember it's just a check and now
now this is actually just waiting for white
i was going to say danny computer wants
queen f3 so once you just go back and say
i messed up you know you know you went the
wrong way when the computer would rather
you go right back to that square but benji
is still i think one thing we'll say from
a technique perspective if benji kind of
has his eyes like let me go win this pawn
if he can do it if he can get rid
of that pawn then he's in a position
you know but i think he'll win um he wants rook
a1 i guess like or queen b3 yeah maybe or queen b6
queen b6 now b6 is spicy
what does black play on queen b6
you almost have to probably like
we need eight what do you sell it because actually
rook b8 rook be it rebirth oh my gosh
it's hilarious we're both just missing it
rook b8 jesus rook b8 wow because in my mind i
was like you have to keep the bishop protected
no you just you give that bishop straight
up that's how the evil goes the other way
boys and girls just watching danny and levy
do commentary um iams do it better who needs
i mean gm's are too perfect i mean it's like it's
like you know art 100 where oh i don't like that
oh i don't like that huge mistake knight h5 knight
h5 or any knight move this is not a move the rain
wants to play that is terribly weakening to
his king side oh knight h5 just sneak in oh man
the thing that is a minute night h5
is now you've got back rank threats
um yeah g7 is covered oh god it's too wrong
that's too sober of a move you need to get
weird with it i almost wonder if benji's just
a little i don't want to say intimidating
he's a little nervous right i feel like he knows
rayne is the strongest player he's faced yet
and he's not playing as aggressive as we saw him
clean up some of the other matches he had right i
mean i feel like he's playing a little timid here
was that a slip or does he want to play a5 rook b8
there was really good but okay rook 8 is fine as
well yeah this is surgical now will rain realize
he can trade queens and push the pawn it's
actually his best move even though ironically
okay and he doesn't does that ironically he
takes and here comes a5 and now if you're benji
oh no he doesn't know a5 e4 just go e4 e5 oh wrong
pawn neither player is using their pawn advantage
use your pawn advantage yeah guys come on oh man
all right e4 all right take h5 take h5 play e4 e4
e5 okay remember we're here we're here for the
uh for the long time not necessarily the good
times we're only giving commentary to help their
understanding no no criticism we know it's hard
to be under a minute that's what i'm saying but
yes neither player has to yet use it but a5 is
the first the first real threat to do so it's so
hard to keep your nerves here as white yeah you're
gonna go all in i think rain's gonna take and
play a4 but that would actually probably just be
be wrong because e i'll put e6 a3 oh my god
what a crazy move because actually if benji
goes for e6 instead of coming back he could lose
yeah okay if benji plays e6 instead of coming
he back actually lose the game but rook f7 king g8
how do you i don't think you can get
back oh smack okay this was the best
move i think from a practical perspective too like
he realizes he can stop the pawn levy and he's
even in a position to like run over and get it
with the king in theory because he's got a
big majority here like that might even work
king g4 now wrong way okay i think king of five in
veggie wins the game he played it i think benji is
going to win this game and we're going to have
overtime kids does reign find rook a5 only move
so that if king g5 i guess at least
wow f4 but then gf but then gs or
maybe stay patient e4 then f6 right
as long as he takes with the e pawn
if the longest benji takes with the epod i
think he's still aha okay oh good move by benji
this is insanity wow this is a real rook ending
ladies and gentlemen let me let me look at these
guys playing good stuff right the rook is properly
balancing defensive measures along the ranks
you know benji is properly shielding his king
while he advances the pawns man diverescue
indeed this is wild that pawn activity and you
know despite white having the extra pawn the rook
is just the terrible it's terrible situation
for the the pawn was up like one rank or even
two ranks on a5 white has serious chances
but you can never move the rook because a2
and oh man where you described that i realized
you're right this might be hard for me okay
that was a big mistake by reign i don't i don't
know that reign will realize he needs to give
up the a pawn to trade it for the f1 he has to
find things like rook a4 uh oh no i think he's
still i think it's good i mean king b3 king e4 oh
you're right you're in time in fact you might lose
oh my gosh rain's gonna save
it same way he did with charlie
crazy i thought there's nothing i mean the pawns
just yeah now king e5 now black is winning no
oh no wow oh no oh my gosh brain's
winning the king upon ending
unbelievable benji can do only benji can
only draw oh it's a draw now yeah but it's
it doesn't it's over i know oh i know he's
gonna say joshua chamberlain strikes again
it's uh yeah he was winning and then he had
to actually you know it's never too late but
i think rain doesn't really care because yeah
obviously he can't win just for the king so
oh man the cinderella story man like
winning the group the only man to
have beaten start ocean i hit the head but
we're not going to get to see the rematch
yeah it's funny because benji's probably a
tougher matchup for sardoche i don't know how
well reigned will handle litz against sardoche
but if it goes to an overtime tiebreaker but
wow what a heartbreaker for benji he was totally
winning in game two not what you saw coming
no absolutely not but uh i i really
hope he doesn't he doesn't uh stop
playing chess i mean well i mean he's not
going to quit what i'm just saying is like
she's one of the players in twitch rivals
coming up by the way um which oh awesome yeah
our partnered obligatory shout out but we'll do
one that isn't required twitch rivals on march
2nd going to be pretty awesome i know that uh
levy roswell will be there but benji is is one
of the confirmed participants on march 2nd
for twitch rivals hand and brain chest style
so yes his growth's been unbelievable i think he's
caught up to being one of the best players in the
field in a month and a half i mean imagine
what happens in a year might be like 1800.
all right well we'll see
if rain finishes the job or
gives us gives us a a clippable stalemate
stephen i don't know that rain is uh
king a6 king c6 maybe 16.6 is the recipe
you need they'll mate stephen it is he
might he might do it for the content but
for content he might do it for the content
he's thinking about doing it for the content
he's not thinking how to mate
here it for the content rain
eclipse can only be a minute long oh queen c6
let's go leave me a minute
i really should learn how to do that end game
no uh
uh i should have been able
to to meet you there i just
i should have taken my time wow what a game jeez
all right well that just happened and uh we're
we're gonna be back with more things that just
happened here and uh more things are gonna happen
um let's keep it happening hey
peter what what's happening
all right we'll be back um i might i might be
uh flashing rain a red card i'm gonna pop out
of this grip six wallet pretty sweet uh we'll
be right back for pogchamps in just a moment
drive benji into stream for an interview no uh
maybe we'll listen to the interview on chess.com
but yeah benji's going to be so upset right now
sardoche will be happy yeah he definitely will
never playing to getting to the semifinals is
impressive nonetheless yeah benji put in a
lot of effort but it still feels bad when
the effort isn't rewarded today he was
kind of the he was his own worst enemy
because once he got this advantage of three
pawns he just he was so obsessed with trading
that he didn't like he didn't consider any
aggressive possibilities whatsoever he was
all about making as many trades as possible and
that kind of came back to bite him especially
this trade here because when he had his rook in
the middle he was still protecting his own pawn
and so he was chilling at this moment but once he
makes the trade it's impossible to keep this pawn
protected and that's part of that was like part
of the reason it it all came fell apart also here
he could have been aggressive he could have tried
to go for the checkmate against black's king
but instead he he just wanted to trade he
wanted to trade and even in this situation
uh ma even though he wanted to get the
trades it wasn't when you're a pawn up
you're no longer guaranteed to win the end game
and rain made you know rain made some mistakes
the pawn up here benji could have gone for the
attack against the king but benji wasn't in an
attacking mindset he just he wanted to make trades
this could have been a sweet finish to the game
where benji could have sacrificed the queen
with the with the knight and and rook working
together for the checkmate but yeah i guess
it wasn't meant to be today unfortunately
uh miles thank you so much for uh gifting
the sub to stormloop thank you so much mouse
and miles coming in with another five gifted uh
to lyle lyell richtor traxo and
tails thank you so much miles
sad yeah i'm a bit sad right now because one
thing is if he loses against a better player
but today he didn't really lose to a better
player he lost to his own nerves in my opinion
which you know it can be interpreted as harsh
but benji is a competitor no one puts more
higher standards to themselves than competitors
and uh benji's gonna be very unhappy about his
his performance today inexperienced streamer
coming in with a sub thank you so much
and we are back here with more pog champs three
presented by grip six our last semi-final just
decided with rain wilson punching his ticket
into the championship but benji starting with
you i know this didn't go the way you you
wanted it to today but a super close match
and uh what were your thoughts on on where it got
away for you or any of your takeaways from this
um i don't know i think i don't think it
was no i mean the first game i just made a
stupid blunder and i rayne played really good i
couldn't it was really hard for me to come back
um in the second game uh i was winning
and then the time pressures got to me
and i yeah started panicking a bit um that was
basically it for me but the rain played played
and i were wondering about that because you were
winning in the second game right and then there
were some moments where you started playing super
fast was that what was going on just the nerves of
the time pressure hard to keep pushing on the
advantage yeah yeah i think that was it i was
just whenever i get below like 30 seconds i start
to panic a lot and yeah that was basically what
costed me but you know is what it is yeah i guess
my my question for rain was going to be how do you
how are you able to make it so dramatic like that
second game you always seem to be fighting back
and we've seen this style with everybody ludwig
loses the first game then he comes back you
in the second game like to go down material for
some reason how do you how do you overcome that
like how do you you stabilize what is it about the
mentality or do you just kind of play the board
range muted hold on
oh
uh yeah the first game was about as solid as game
as i've played in a long time and i felt really
good about that and he blundered and gave up his
bishop there and then kind of got on the ropes
and had pieces forked so i did get a little lucky
there but it was a solid game and the second game
um i don't know he had um it was something i just
wasn't used to that uh the way the center was
locked up and it's one of those things where you
have to be like how much pressure is on each pawn
like i've got a knight on the pawn and a bishop
on a pawn and a queen on a pawn and i've got this
pawn on the pawn and and i just lost track of of
that and in my head i saw this fork i was like
oh there's a fork with the queen and the bishop
and but i didn't even have the fork it wasn't
even real because his knight was there so i don't
know what i was thinking but i just my brain just
kind of shut down in that little middle part of
the game in the second game and then um and then
and then i'm like listen he's up three points
um uh i think i play a little faster than he
does so let me just hang in there solid as long
as i can and maybe pawn by pawn claw my way up
back which i did for a large chunk of it and then
he got a really good endgame strategy and if he
had rammed those pawns down my king's throat i
would have been dead as a doornail um but um i
got lucky because of the time pressure as well and
then at the end danny you never taught me how to
mate with a king and a queen against a cage i knew
you were going to blame me and blame me for that
that's what you teach five-year-olds when they're
learning chess and i don't know it's danny's fault
people were like rain is so strong he should
know how to check me with the king and queen i'm
like i agree that should not be on me i mean you
you should have this one okay okay well i gotta
listen i put a wrench in it i gotta have it right
did you get that yeah i did good i wanna ask benji
a question um benji you so when you were playing
uh your first game i took a look at you know
your your rating progress chart and everything
you've had your chest.com account since 2018.
um a lot of us you know you we we saw you beat
stardust to nothing keep your nerves better
in that match kind of two questions for you number
one like how how have you gained 550 points in a
month like how much do you work on your chest and
number two like where do you see your potential
do you have any like goal beyond this event like
i mean obviously you wanted to win i'm sure you
felt confident enough to win but so what's your
goal do you have a rating goals how much do you
work on your chest period and do you have a future
goal for like a certain elo um yeah i mean i mean
i started i started playing chess i mean i played
a bit as a kids but never like anything serious
um so i knew like how the pieces moving stuff
but i started playing about two months ago
for like the first time since since i was like
five um and yeah i was grinding like every day um
and then you know i saw pogchamps obviously i've
seen i've seen the past pogchamps um i was like
enough to get an invite to this um and that's you
know i'm a competitive guy so i put a lot of time
into it like an hour or two a day um just working
on puzzles working on um just playing um and then
obviously getting coached by hammer has helped a
ton i definitely wouldn't have got here without
getting coached by him um yeah he's been he's been
a massive help um yeah i've been playing a lot and
uh like yeah as i said two hours a day i think
i i still want to play chess off this you know
this is not gonna it's not gonna end i wanna
continue playing this as a hobby i really
enjoy it and you know hopefully you know i want
to start working towards the the 1500s 1600s
uh eventually um so yeah i don't really see the
stuffing anywhere you're playing in twitch rivals
in a couple days right march 2nd so it's uh yeah
it's not just yet yeah yeah rain is it the hat
that brought you the good luck today i mean
you want to talk about that a little bit
it's a hat yeah okay yeah it's all about
the hat it's all about the hat danny um
yeah i um i was like you know
i need a cool [ __ ] chess hat
how's that gonna go down so i went to my
old friend etsy she has a store online
and i found this bad boy it took them forever
i wanted to wear it for the whole thing took
them like three weeks to get to me now they're
going to sell your welcome vendor whoever you are
you're gonna sell about a thousand
chess wars hats for all the nerds
just for my nerd cred anyway uh but listen benji
is one quarter my age and equal my skill and he's
really [ __ ] good and dude i mean you you if you
you will absolutely beat me in the next podcast
there's no question about it um you have far
more raw talent than i do and i'm i'm a very
very old man in fact i'm way too old to be doing
this this [ __ ] with all these twitch streamers
have you learned your kecks and your your pepe
laughs and whatnot are you did you you're just
here to play chess i don't even know i don't
even know what that is i barely know how to
check my email yeah but you do know how good
sardosha is because we've talked about that right
i mean so what are you looking ahead to the
final obviously that's tomorrow what are your
uh what are your what are your own words of
coaching for yourself for that match tomorrow
oh it's tomorrow i'm busy tomorrow shoes um
yeah i saw him play ludwig and um boy he was
good oh i thought it was gonna be the other way
i thought you were gonna say it was bad and okay
yeah he he he played he played great against
ludwig and he he really understands spacing
on the board and you know positional chess
and tactical chess and where to attack and
lines of attack and he he's he's he's going to be
a very um difficult adversary well benji you beat
sardosh2o so any advice for rain um he does get a
bit nervous uh at least i think he did against me
but maybe he's fixed that um but well you you make
people nervous i mean that face is intimidating
yeah i i i hope so he's he's really good he's
really good i will be it will be a good final
all right guys well um thank you so much for for
joining us and again benji thanks for playing
podcamps we knew but it was a close call because
you're a you're a professional fortnight player uh
straight streamer but you know now now maybe the
future of being a professional podchamps player
might be on the horizon too you were awesome man
seriously and it was it was inspiring to watch
where you went like levy said 500 points i haven't
gained 500 points in ever danny don't talk about
it we don't talk about my rating on this show
because it's not going anywhere good but rain
way to go man good luck tomorrow in the
final versus sardosh we'll see you then
and uh thanks thanks both guys thank you thanks
guys bye guys thank you all right well there we go
we had our two players join us and that is the two
players that will be playing in tomorrow's final
rain versus sardosh you know one of the
things about rayne and obviously he's a super
um you know kind of jokes around about it but he's
been playing chess for a long time and i wonder
about the the experience factor versus like the
grind of of the of like the recent history factor
and i was trying to touch on this a little
bit with carl levy but i love your thoughts
too the the idea that i think sometimes rain
has a little more experience because he's been
he's been bouncing between 1100 and 1300 for
25 years right it's different than than rising
from zero to 1400 and i wonder if sometimes
that just pays off in some of these matches
uh you know i want to say yes and no but we can't
discredit the fact that you know benji's uh first
of all he's he's younger he's got better nerves
uh and uh he can manage his adrenaline better
and also like this kid you know like he plays
one of the most intense games in front of the
you know he's he's signed he's a 16 year old
17 year old kid who's he signed to already
play one of the most competitive video games if
not the most competitive video game on earth so
i i honestly feel like it was uh it was a
heavyweight knockout in that first in that first
game meaning that first you ran that lopsided
yeah you're right like if you ran it ten times
man i feel like that could have been five five
and he got or four six six four he he got the
one wrong start to the game so but that's how the
cookie crumbles but i'm excited because i think
long term he's got the highest growth trajectory
possible that's what i think he's very talented i
think you're i think you're right and i think um i
mean he he's the only guy that beat sardosh so far
and he beat him 2-0 and you're right i think that
in in hindsight looking at it it was that that you
know just french gone wrong right which should
be a lesson to all french players to just stop
playing the french i think that's the message we
got out of this that's the message uh i well right
you gotta we gotta we got a frenchman in the final
who doesn't even play the french she plays the
sicilian okay so he goes to italy for his openings
right and i and then we got rain wilson and um
what a final it's gonna be let's talk a little
bit about what's coming up here in just a second
we've got nico versus tebow the winner of
that will meet michelle carrey in the final
um again also also an interesting match up i think
i feel like given some of the things i've seen
tubo do i want to say like maybe a slight nod but
nico when she's got it when she's got it rolling
she plays faster and and and her intuition is
really on point at times with how to play certain
positions in fact sometimes that becomes the
weakness so she plays too fast but your thoughts
on who you would who you would give the slight nod
to before we dive into the consolation semi-final
i i it's so tough to choose because if honestly
if nico took a little bit of time in the open and
got some openings uh kind of in her in her in her
toolbox for chess she'd be she'd be she'd be easy
a thousand but she needs to make it out of the
first five ten moves to get that that flow and
tubbo needs to kind of not get nervous like like
[ __ ] like he he's gotta like absorb that and be
like wait a minute you know or he's got to punish
those opening mistakes in the first five ten
moves but if it gets out into the kind of middle
game the time like you said uh and the kind of
positions that nico seems to be good at with the
openings of the bishops and the knights i gotta
give a very slight nod to her probably but it's
so tough to choose but i'm excited it's coming up
well they got to maintain their nerves they gotta
look for blunders out of the openings avoid time
pressure they also got to make sure that they've
got the energy they need with their favorite yerba
mate is regenerative it's been around for 25 years
it is also interesting just like reigns chessylo
it's right it's been it's been the same for
25 years and uh i hope rayne's listening to
that hey you said that i didn't say that i you
said it rain it was him he said it uh guyaki
urbamate uh you can spam the emotes and chat
they're giving away cases it's a lot of fun
we really do appreciate their support of course
in all our sponsors uh because they're they're
helping make these events even more awesome
and giving away cool stuff to the community
so use your emote spam it for a chance to win
some cases of guyaki herbal mate well we are
going to be right back with more pogchamps
3 presented by grip6 in just a few moments
hello that pinned onto my board for years that
that picture was the photo i looked at every day
for years and years and years oh i think we are
on the chess.com live show so we're talking about
our journeys with michelle and i was just saying
that um my biggest dream was to to get into the
olympic team i wanted to be a chess olympian and
and i had this photograph of me as a 12 year old
with the olympic symbol and it was on my wall and
it it motivated me every day to keep going because
chess is a game i really loved
as a kid but it's not just
playing you have to show up at the lessons you
need to go to the chess club you need to train
and you need to you need to also take defeats um
in a gracious way and realize that every game you
lose is actually a very valuable learning lesson
so instead of being upset on how how poorly i lost
i always i think i was trying to take it as
it's part of the learning process and just
keep growing and keep improving from from one's
mistakes to do it better next time to not commit
the same mistakes and it felt amazing to actually
go get into the olympic team because just because
you put a picture on your wall as a kid it
doesn't mean it will become true it doesn't
mean that suddenly your goal will materialize
but i think it helped me a lot with motivation to
to know what i want to achieve so that for me in
chess that was the biggest but once i got onto
the team maybe i should have had another big goal
because i i from then on i didn't have any other
like huge milestone i want to achieve i there
are titles in chess so i had i had the titles too
on my board the woman international master the
woman grandmaster the international master but
i i for instance never thought that i could
become a grandmaster and maybe i should have
been more ambitious maybe i should have set out
the goal i won the highest title in chess um but
i didn't maybe maybe i i should have aimed even
higher but the olympic team was a big deal for me
and now what's big deal for me is that there's
so many of you who come into the chess world
and what you were saying is that you really like
the game of chess and you really like our chess
community you like you like your stay here and
you you feel welcome then this is a very positive
experience to you and i think nowadays these are
what what i consider kind of an accomplishment
not just from me but the community that that
we are doing something that that's meaningful
yeah wow i feel like i'm learning so much about
you i'm glad we're getting this time just to
hang out and and watch jess and and get to
know each other even more because obviously
we have a relationship as student coach
um we have a stream which is really cool
sorry michelle i'm interrupting you there
but i realized it was a stream stream caption
because i was watching chess.com and they were
watching our stream so it was like an infinite
infinite stream but i was so lost in my thought
process that i didn't think about the tech side
apologies there chance.com team i will i'll not
do that the matrix which show is the real one but
also for you michelle so now that you are you
said that you've done so many physical challenges
for your serious challenge accepted but this is
the first actual very very mentally challenging
goal that you set out that you wanted to train
as a chess professional and how far you can
introducing the grip 6 belt the
only belt on the market with the no
gut pinch guarantee the grip 6 is so light and
thin that you'll barely even notice it's there
it's smooth low profile design makes this belt
the most comfortable belt in the world overly
confident much you're damn right because on top
of being the most comfortable belt in the universe
each grip 6 belt comes with our a3 gear and damn
tee meaning if you don't like any belt for any
reason at any time or in any condition you can
just contact us and we'll give you a full refund
and we are back here with pogchamps 3 presented
by grip6 remember the limited time chess swag
and and gear whether it's the chess buckles or
chess wallets is still available if you go to
grip6.compogchamps or go.just.com script6 i've
actually got the wallet right here in front of
me it's pretty awesome and uh it's anyway have
you seen the wallet levy did you get did you get
a wallet or they only said it to me what no of
course i mean even if i didn't of course i would
lie on behalf of the company i mean capitalism
baby no but i do you know danny it's funny
it actually is super cool and i will i will
like throw some inadvertent shade i got a new i
ended up getting this new like magnetic apple
apple wallet and i don't like it because my
cards get stuck in it like legit and i don't have
a way to get them out the thing about this is like
i literally have it's like the same thinness and
i press this thing and my thing and my in my cards
pop out so but the problem is now i've split up my
debit cards i've got like my grip six wallet and
then i've got the app so i'm i'm this is clearly
a first world problem that i'm now venting about
but i do prefer the grip 6 wallet for that
purpose because it pops my cards out instantly
because i got sticky fingers i use a lot
of lotion on my hands because there's
you know dry skin okay i i like
when the way my brain works when
an interesting subject is being discussed like my
brain is constantly trying to fire off different
jokes and i i could have gone in so many different
directions i've given you so much material yeah
i like first you did you know we we plugged a
different streaming service now we discredited
the physical product of another company um
what else have we done today we're on a roll um
hey if apple wants to fix their issues so that
their cars are easy to get on apple can't do
it but i'm telling you the grip six months
better let's look at this hi chess people hello
double what's your move buddy oh it's
nico's move never mind we're an abomination
all right okay um right uh
okay so who's he listening to
he was he's talking to friends before the matches
i think they're like doing some oh and he moved
this he moved his camera danny he moved it
oh so now we got to recrop him that's fine
well first of all he moved his camera because he
realized for his view he was on top of the board
that means we gotta gotta recrop him and bring his
camera back up thank you wait wait danny someone
someone sat nico down and told her to stop playing
the bird oh this could be very bad for tubbo
she doesn't play a fort who is this person and
why didn't she listen to me our i gave her her
first lesson like before the event started
weeks ago and i was like let's commit now
let's commit now to something else
besides the birds and she wasn't into it
yeah well did you give her something or
did you just say something besides the bird
yeah we talked about e4 in fact the fried liquor
in fact she loved it she loved the fried like we
were you know we were bishop c4 knight g5 attack
seven all day um but i did say at the time
and and obviously to her credit she she's you know
nico's been playing chess since she was a kid for
those who don't know she's played in scholastic
tournaments and she she had a chess club at school
and she i think she got taught the birds
and old habits die hard right when you know
something you don't want to walk away from it
um that is the worst opening you could teach
a kid like if a coach is teaching the bird they
should be fired yeah who is that let's find it
um let's also listen into tubbo and
just see what he's screaming about now
yes it's always content here oh i thought
that was a free form for a second okay
that is the only free square i have right now
i'm not one for giving pieces away this early on
so i'm gonna just i'm gonna just play it safe
there's no there's no like shame in retreating god
i'm so tired um right if i lose i'm blaming it on
me being tired just so you're all aware i am i'm
shamelessly blaming it on my on my on my status i
kind of want to push this pawn forward like that
it's protected by one two three and it's attacked
by one so if it's taken boom boom um boom what if
it's not boom okay yeah no they didn't go for
that and it's also protected by one down there
okay right i need i need to be more aggressive
i always fall behind because i'm
never normally aggressive enough
okay i don't even know if that's true but levy go
ahead no i i i was it was just i was cracking up
because you know he played d4 and his logic there
was that you know takes takes takes that's what
a lot of people do they prove they try to prove
themselves right and they don't think what else
can my opponent do they see one thing if you
try to play a move five ways it works one way
it doesn't it doesn't work you can't play it you
can't just oh it's a one out of six chance but
i love how he plays that move nico plays a
pawn move on the opposite side of the board
it's so hard to play nico because she just
plays she plays quick solid moves takes no risk
you kill yourself thinking and then she
just overwhelms you and blah blah blah
yeah he played d4 everyone love you silence she
just calmly played h3 and did so kind of quickly
and even though h3 was objectively not as good as
c4 to avoid the trade and this actually might trap
the bishop but but it's a good move and now she
plays b5 she's uh yeah if nico again someone who
sticks with chess i mean i think that she's she's
done a lot of things um like just intuitively
the fact that she's playing so quickly um
she could be a very good player for sure
and tubbo by the way chubbo is one of the few
uh streamers in the event that my kids knew
about one and they're like oh who's playing in pog
champs and i went through the list and then i was
like tubbo apparently he's big like he streams
like a game called minecraft ever heard of it
yeah so the interesting thing is like i mean
again i'm thinking like can i joke about it
like obviously i uh i have first of all younger
brother uh shout out to leo love that love that
kid uh he plays a lot of minecraft and uh so shout
out leo just got a huge shout out in front like
a hundred thousand people who can show that to
his friends um he plays a lot of minecraft and
growing up he was like eight nine years old he
was watching all these different minecrafters and
i've played minecraft once you know i i just i
don't know and i never really was was too into
it but he uh yeah he knows all these guys he
learned to curse watching minecraft youtubers
probably watching toppo i wouldn't even doubt
that to be honest i don't know who he watched
i mean as a new york city kid you don't need
another source to teach you how to curse
fair for sure um all right well what's
happened here so ooh oh i was just about
to go back in to see what's happened until
what's happened in front of us is enough to
focus on i don't know i don't know what
her it's not it's not about criticizing
the blunder i don't know what exactly
her plan was with that like i think that
it's off track with the things she had been
doing right she expanded the pawns and you
would really have loved to play to move like c4
to keep these pieces on the edge of the board
definitely would have been the best but um joe can
play 95 and tumble has not taken the knight yet so
he doesn't see it maybe yeah he uh he thinks that
he's blundered like she pushed the pawn b5 to get
the knight out and now she took but there's he
doesn't see it oh my god did he play bishop v6
totally didn't see it she plays so fast it freaks
people out yeah 95 was a was a was a free pony
again for those who uh keeping score at home that
that's what we were freaking out about so wowzers
you know like danny uh i'm gonna make a personal
reference again like you know lucy my wonderful
girlfriend she'll be playing right and she'll be
playing a 10 10 minute game she's like a thousand
and her opponent plays every move like in a second
loses all their pieces like making blunders all
and she's sitting there like babe i don't know
what to do my opponent is playing so fast i'm like
they're down nine pieces honey like you know oh no
the feel of it for sure it's and uh okay e3 is
played which again are not a bad move from the
perspective of of nico she's trying to open things
up but if temple took here yeah just good stuff
this is good too yeah knight b3 is a good move but
she's just gonna play rookie too right it's it's
funny that on the move where she has no choice
she thinks the most right fascinating too right
that's an interesting psychology no she doesn't
she does it apparently she does she took me seven
oh my gosh she's got a fork coming on c6 if rook
to b8 is played oh my god that's insane tubbo
might actually like just tunnel vision this and
just be rude knight c6 rook b7 oh my this is nuts
it's nuts yeah if that's taken so let's say
it's my go i take that i do i go forward
with the exchange um and i take the queen that
gives me like a direct line there i could then
what i can do is i can then line that bishop up
there and i can push the bishop forward to them
threaten the castle and it wouldn't be able to be
taken by the king that's a pretty good idea yes
it they had us in the first half it was very
very good then it kind of cooled off a little
bit but he's got the right he saw the queen sees
the other side or i could take that pawn there
i could take that pawn i'd lose that i'd then
take that but then the bishop would escape no
i've got a like there's no easy way for me to
save this oh well i mean i guess i can just fret
i can always just move the castle
i mean it should have crossed my
mind quite significantly more then she has
just won a pawn and i am not a fan of that
yeah i could just do that i could just say
that oh look at nico play knight c6 okay now
okay see now the queen's threatened see that
was a mistake i should have seen that one coming
i wasn't paying enough attention
i need to focus more all right
oh my god i knew it he was gonna play queen d5 i
was gonna call this if he plays queen d5 knight
e7 wins the queen doesn't it it does but if she
doesn't see it queen d5 threatens bishop takes
h3 oh my gosh she's gonna she might take the
rook and then he's gotta see queen takes bishop
because he's looking down this way but knight e7
that's why you always look for checks oh it takes
the rook oh oh my god he takes the got away with
that big time oh i was damn i would have looked
so smart i was gonna call it but i actually
didn't think he was going to play queen d5
i thought he would play queen d7 but he went the
whole distance he he doesn't and now she's got a
oh man this is a wild game danny knight c6
was of course best but i think it's a wild
game levy that might end faster than all of
us want as fans and commentators because the
fact that tubbo has already highlighted i miss
highlight that the light squares are a problem
yes he blundered to get here with queen d5 and
again nico was winning the queen everybody with
this tactic but the fact that he already saw
that makes me feel like that he he's he's gonna
see bishop takes h3 and unless nico okay nice c6
by the way oh bishop h3 she might play queen a1
yeah she might play queen a1 but she's gotta
oh never mind okay okay so we're in trade mode
yeah we are in trade mode so what is the count
black has a bishop white has two pawns but bishop
takes h3 is of course winning and if you don't
play it yeah this is this is now like and look how
well's nico's this is now one of those games that
like don't trust the eval bar right because yes
black is up a piece but if she if he doesn't go
for this plan which particularly goes really goes
really strong i mean she's got a lot of pawns for
the piece it's not going to be an easy cleanup
bishop c4
okay rook d1 yeah if tabo doesn't
go back to attacking the king
i don't think that he's going to win this
game unless she blunders but i just mean
conceptually like yeah he's
got it i agree with you
you alright yeah sorry i might but i had a long
show yesterday with a car now this one apparently
my voices you know i i'm not a professional
streamer like you i don't i don't you know
your voice muscles are very strong uh danny i'm a
professional chess content creator oh sorry yeah
it's the more where it's like linkedin you know
it's like uh you know you got to add more words
to your resume so it gets to the second line you
know what i mean replenish the nourishment and the
productivity of the you gotta yeah i'm so insecure
they invented a chief title just to make me feel
okay if chess officer what a joke cco danny
danny the trade oh she took ah she took e4 i know
the knight was pinned for the win it's still
pinned she might see it because there's not a
lot of pieces on the board i think she's gonna
bring her queen she's gonna play like queen e5
or something cool right but 95 queen c3 25
probably the most logical but e4 would win
back material on the spot everybody because the
bishop has pinned the background checkmate um
oh this is and it's not a hard move to see
actually if you if you go through the chest
thought process of checks captures attacks it's
the third option she plays oh no bishop isn't far
all right well elmo's got enough
bouncing heads to keep every adh kid
adhd kid in his audience happy
let's go ahead and check that out
what's the bathroom everything is a
little bit gridlocked and i hate it
look how he hates it but it's totally winning
i love when someone's winning yeah everything's
a little bit what video game is this music from
sorry i am just not his
demographic i'm having a seizure
watching all the pieces yeah i want to get
rid of that pig because that's really annoying
oh sonic i'm gonna do that
i don't play any non-dmc oh did we mute him i
don't hear i don't even know why anyone isn't and
now i mean i just waiting for a next stream okay i
see an attack i see an attack if that stays there
if i can line up my queen there i can check
there and then the king has to move i don't
know because the king moves there that
scarf is my whole thing never mind okay
interesting
isn't it
he might be the first sub 1000 in history to spot
it being able to happen for his opponent yeah
because pretty quickly too i mean we saw several
games yesterday where it was legit just missed
yeah normally you see it for yourself you're
like oh can i do it and you click and it's
like oh yeah i'm gonna you don't even
you know i have to warn my subscribers
to stop doing that like just because you
can doesn't mean that you should right
niko threatened the option you have the
option not the obligation to take on busan
um okay nico by the way look at the credit
the rook lift and the rook slide to hit g7
and obviously this is still totally
winning for black with best play
doubles just up a free piece but i actually
feel like nico right now levy is playing with
a more coordinated plan than tobo is right i
mean she's coordinating her pieces for a goal
tebow has uh is struggling to realize just how
winning his position is here yeah he keeps saying
words like gridlocked but that's you know you got
to stay away from kind of abstract just terms in
general it's ultimately really it all comes down
to what can you attack and what can they attack
and and and it's mate i mean it's force made on
the board i think after bishop g2 so bishop g2
when the king moves to g1 you can actually take
h3 which is a fork of brook and the checkmate um
but again dude he's we're looking at his he's not
even looking for aggressive moves with the bishop
let's let's go back and look again he's all
about trying to coordinate the rook and queen
yeah he's actually labeling a move
right now which would throw the game
oh yeah so like that move loses quick
f6 okay wait i think i see a move boom
no because then that will be lost
okay but then rook team won tobo
check king now probably goes there i don't
think the king is going to go back yep okay
good now i can that was oh my god like that oh
queen h1 was made 87 22 was also pretty good
then like that kind of like that you
know that yes you can see the metal for
consistency he's been obsessed with the
battery queen and rook here for many moves
oh brain firing on all of its available cylinders
at the moment which indeed is not very many
all right that was pretty funny this
kid gets great he's hilarious but
hello i think he he and benji are like by far the
youngest participants in the event like they're
like 16 17 like who is the third youngest player
in the field man it's like like these guys are you
know for the chess that they've played it's uh it
is pretty good i'll be honest when i was 16 17 it
wasn't very cool like at that point you're in high
school you kind of have a sense of self but like
the younger kids watching like 12 and 13 like
it is really like it's getting more cool to
play chess now it was never cool back in the
day now it's like oh you play chess oh damn
i'll watch that oh rook c4 played i think temple's
gonna see rook d1 in fact he's uh suddenly stopped
drumming air drums by the way the air drums also
just got a lot cooler what he did um but uh no
he does see it okay it looks like he's gonna yeah
this is gonna be taking this home now short of um
yeah no queen f1 like i don't know it's
just a very it's an example of anybody
you hang your queen it's still a game
but bishop d3 now and or queen d3 and
all right tab on doubles about to
play bishop d3 he has played it
don't even have to take the rook but
okay but suddenly he's in the zone
i think michelle wanted this i think she wants
revenge yeah yeah i think you want revenge
we could have had a double rematch we could we
almost had benji versus sartosh and a rematch
of this of this group a double rematch of the
brat of their respective brackets but you know
i don't think that was been a storyline that was
clear all along at all i mean um you know okay
see if this ends cleanly and we don't whenever
someone is preparing to get a second queen levy
you know where my brain goes stalemate stephen
yes like yes what you got to do at this point
you got to have the skill to set it up so you
got to play like a5 you got to make sure you
have no legal moves but that's good now you got
to go g5 i can't believe we're coaching this but
yeah get rid of the pawns last legal move
that's first on your agenda play g5 mm-hmm
oh battery i don't i don't i don't think
uh we'll get it we'll get a still me
even any although if king a7 any if he plays queen
b7 oh my god no just queen b it's made obviously
g5 okay oh no wow wow okay clean clean
that was clean hey clean stuff yeah he did no
once he i mean we were we were anticipating a
possible stalemate and by the way that's not
totally unfair tubbo is actually the one of
the only stalemates we've had in the event until
until reigns uh king and queen disaster but um
but no once he won that material levy i mean to
be fair to him if you go back to where rook d1
happened and to his credit he had been obsessed
with this battery for like 20 moves and and and
that was his main goal even though he was missing
a lot of other opportunities i i i know i'm like
uh you know obviously it's our job to entertain
and provide content but i really do believe that
we were listening to him levy and let's go back
like from right here he was obsessed with this
idea and he created it right he legit stopped
checkmate along the way he went for his battery
and once he won the queen it was like a grand
master took over this was a very smooth victory
from there on out yes uh the the truth is this
uh for for all of the kind of like joking and
everything like that he his one thing that he did
wrong in this game was that he didn't win fast
that's it he didn't execute the cleanest win from
the middle game but he had a plan he negated all
of his opponent's attempts at creating counter
play and then he won when he got his chance so
at 800 no seriously no uh nothing more needs to
be said he had a plan he stuck with it and he
delivered and we are gonna deliver with more pog
champs three presented by grip6 when we come back
great job
we've got a five minute break we
should resume shortly that's my
right we have to be more on our a-game next time
because we blundered some pawns last game and we
didn't look through the actions like we didn't
look through too much of our like consequences
we could have messed some stuff up
get down
what's going on
shoulder back the whole shebang
hey i won i know that was
awesome oh one round exactly
we do with twitter
oh you did it did you did you did
you miss a checkmate this time
i don't know i don't think i did good good i
mean you still won though what would be really
bad is if you missed the checkmate and then lost
yeah yeah thank me for my sub forward oh ludwig
oh i missed ludwig's sub let me find
it let me find it i missed this sub
oh god where is it when did you sub blood glad
you haven't announced your sub it's not there
it's not my alert feed share share the sub
thank you for the sub ludwig i don't i don't
see the sub though i don't did he just lie
i don't know let me check okay we haven't gotten
to the next game yet okay okay oh but look at look
at you go check mate and stuff mm-hmm yeah yeah
you know what that means yeah i know what that
means that's for sure yeah wait watch this
clip let me watch this clip i'm curious now
a porn and i am not a fan of that yeah i
could just do that i could just say that
look at niko play knight c6 okay now
okay see now the queen's threatened see that
was a mistake i should have seen that one coming
i wasn't paying enough yes look at
you porn and i am not a fan of that
i think i counted that pretty well
this is only the beginning
and we are back here getting set for the second
game in the consolation bracket semi-final remind
the community that we are also raising money for
charity remember that all of the players have
picked charities and uh you might you might find
one you'd like but we'll remind you of that here
in just a second but we've already raised more
than 50 000 together because every dime is matched
by chess.com so if you're watching and we're
getting down to it here all of these funds go to
really important causes and we we do hope to reach
our goals it would be incredible so please please
consider it if you're liking what you see in terms
of any of those charities um go ahead throw in
every dime supported by chess.com and i might
you know you see st jude's there right it's a
pretty awesome one i know that reigns charity is
super near and dear to him and his wife's heart
um the work they do in haiti and of course there's
a lot of others too so if you see see something
you're into supporting throw in some cash and
uh chess.com will match it all right here we go
we're on to game two for the semifinals levy
this could be it this could be the final
final game the semis and uh we will know our
final four participants for the finals of the
consolation in the champions bracket i just
wanted to say that the chess community has
an incredible amount of support in it for like
donors to different streamers but those people
those people and a lot of other people
show up for these charity events day like
yesterday i was playing blitz and someone in my
community said if you crossed 27.50 today because
i was 27 48 which was my highest ever so i'll
donate 27.50 to charity two people did that so i
crossed it so pancreatic cancer research yesterday
got over five thousand dollars because wow no and
i know obviously we know that hikaru has done some
incredible streams recently raising collectively
over seven hundred thousand dollars in the last
couple times he did uh charity drives right i
mean so for sure and we know that many of you have
been donating and done some incredible stuff and
yesterday we we really had a blast uh crushing
past our 25 000 goal um so thank you so much to
the community both in in part with this event and
all the other streams that uh that they contribute
towards them um e4 played by devil does nico
know it's her move i guess she does she's just
kind of getting zen looks like it's
like me when i when i wake up before i
face my children i really i couldn't imagine oh no
she's just texting someone oh i'll check my phone
oh no yeah no it's okay that you switch to the
birds after someone else's advice that's not a
big deal um um i don't i don't know what to do um
uh this is awkward uh thanks for that massive 250
donation to charity look at that 250 bucks from
destroy computers and that's not his first dono
during this event levy that guy that guy i don't
know the total off the top of my head but he has
been awesome thank you so much destroy computers
and by the way i'm with you let's destroy all
computers like i would literally tear down
this business model if we just want to go back
to nothing just playing one thing i really
loved about the queen's gambit just on
the topic of trying to like kill time while
seeing figuring out what's going on with nico
um queen's gambit the one thing i loved no answers
to like chess positions they would hang out and be
like yo that's a bad move and like no one could
you couldn't pull out a phone and be like no
idiot look like it was great just talk about chess
it's amazing it's not like anymore she's playing
fast and uh thank you so much for the donations
continuing to roll in if we don't shout out every
one of you we do love you um all right okay we got
an open sicilian happening here look at the uh the
opening repertoires that have gone nuts and look
at the the whatever's going on at dubbo street
you can't even see him oh it's komodo hype baby
that's what i'm talking about that's uh i love her
should i say played by nico they're not the
most common move in an open sicilian but
you know a good one here she's trying to support
the trade on c5 and this one when she close it up
okay nico she just plays so fast man she plays so
fast she plays so fast danny she plays so quickly
it's just like like nico
slow down just a little bit
i hope she doesn't drive this fast like i mean
but if it works it works
but she can't castle now that's the problem
will she figure out she can castle queenside
okay doubles just by a little sleepy earlier but
um let's listen into him the meds
seem to have kicked in he's back
oh wait a minute oh no that's why thank
you andrews for 100 donations let's do it
oh yeah me too
i want to put pressure i'm getting this piece out
oh man nico is just yeah whatever that is living
highway to the danger zone
right there yeah that's fun
this sounds like a highway to the day
it could be a highway to the danger zone
let's put this way every dancing emote on twitch
was made for that music every single one like pepe
d i'm talking cat dance i mean you name it it was
made for that um oh man i wouldn't be surprised
oh god it's like mate queen reddit we're headed
toward mate on a seven oh double [ __ ] get your
boy in wisconsin take the queen and don't look
back nico yeah send us to overtime whatever oh
[ __ ] and that's why you pay more attention holy
crap i'm an idiot it's fine we can bring this back
from nico dude no reaction like zero she took the
queen she's she's the same she get it's the same
it's like that should have happened in the first
game this new trash like i mean what is going like
like what is i know it's it's the music
it's the awkward you know tom cruise you
know erotica jokes it's tubbo dropping
bombs it's the botes gambit yeah like
like first of all is she okay like i don't
like she we got tubbo out here jamming out
things flying all over the screen she's just
like she she hella chilling is that her home in
the studio is she mm-hmm we'll protest gambit
there's awkward checkmates that could happen
here with the rook with the two rooks on on the
open lines with the king yep this yes their arm
i don't want this match to end too quickly we got
we got some community donations we're driving and
they are coming in thank you so much so let's keep
the chest going as long as we can nico and tubbo
let's throw for some donut yeah seriously more
money gets raised for charity this way it's
good you know it's like it's like charity boxing
matches you don't want to knock out in round one
you gotta go 12 rounds as marcelo's wallace
would say your ass goes down in the fifth
but don't do it don't go down to the fifth go go
bruce willis and change the ending to that movie
yes i haven't you know speaking of movies i
haven't watched the movie in forever i got such
a bad attentions man i'm just on my phone the
whole time what's the last movie you've watched
you have family night like with the movie um we
do actually we watched um we we usually impact
my family movie night tonight we watched seoul
the disney soul you ever seen that one the guy
like dead the guy dies but then he comes he comes
back and anyway disney's soul it was pretty good
i probably shouldn't even talk about disney
movies anywhere because they'll sue us um yeah um
um last the last adult movie not adult
movie the last the last grown-up time i had
yeah yeah all right last uh the last i don't
even know where we go from here just uh danny
what was it what was it all right what's funny
is regardless of how wild that got with tubbo
i think if he finds rook d7 winning
winning the queen back once again
um okay he does wow we what is going
to happen in this game i have no idea
well we got some huge donuts i wasn't paying
attention we're over 27 000 maybe it's been that
way for a while but thank you yeah this is uh no
longer very easy at all taboo's got a bishop and a
pawn but he's got back rank problems and rook d2
problems rookie two would be a very timely move
don't go rook d1 huge mistake beginners make just
defending pieces but pinning themselves don't go
rook d1 ooh i don't she oh if she had seen rook f7
yeah but it's you know you got to visualize back
rank and he's got to visualize it too but will
he play bishop g4 oh no but you could also you
would also see it if you just slow down a little
bit you gotta just slow down yes a little bit
it feels sometimes like the first idea nico sees
she just teaches goes for and you know it's kind
of like that logic mentality you know he was like
i just play you know i'm not trying to stress too
much i'm not but you gotta counterbalance
that with also your you know bloodthirsty
desire to just win and destroy anything in
your path so you gotta hit the pause button
sometimes yep well i mean not in exactly the
same context here but i mean you and i both
coach professionally and you do have students
that that are like that even even of the most
talented nature where you start to realize or you
start to get them to see like hey just because you
see a move and you see these ideas so fast doesn't
mean you have to play them so fast right like and
you really start to try to give them techniques
to develop discipline by the way b5 was played
instantly by nico and a great move by nico she
played it instantly there you go bishop b3c
yeah just that if she sees c4 now she might play
rook d1 okay she sees her there you go sorry guys
what are we gonna add no she just traps it and
uh i i was gonna say this ultimately chess is uh
is a lens into how you behave in kind of all
elements of your life so like i taught a kid
from from second grade up to sixth and for five
straight years he had the same problem in chess
as he had in school his parents were like we can't
get him to slow down he comes back with a 90 on
the math exam because he added three plus five in
a calculation made it nine and he he knows all the
concepts he knows how to do it he just first one
done lost 10 points because of silly mistakes so
it's everywhere man it's not just just you too
fast everywhere it is psychology in a lot of
ways and and uh and it doesn't mean people don't
you know i mean we've i've had students that were
you know maybe a lot more timid at certain times
and then they like grow and and all of a sudden
they get confidence for whatever reason you know
and now now they're doing things at a super high
level with the knowledge that was always in there
but it's just being executed so so many things
can change but chess really is psychology and by
the way nico if we just go back to this position
he played instantly but this this a6 b5 c4 like
no hesitation bring the rooks to the second rank
she's crushing it now yes the only chance oh the
rook oh did she see that oh yeah she's going over
to kids i i think it's happening let's hope joshua
chamberlain doesn't live on that one and that we
don't get a stalemate or anything but if we go
to overtime we're gonna have a lot more fun today
oh totally i mean nico this is her
this will be her second armageddon
uh she won the first against rubius right or was
that who she won the uh against she played ruby as
she won the first he won the second they went to
armageddon i think okay i think that's how it went
there was one chance if you if you back up i just
want to show this to people uh for for for taboo
before he gave the check on a8 he could have
walked his king and maybe checkmated yep right
that it's the one way you're going to win here
the your rook is doing something called cutting
off the king yeah or even right here if you keep
the king trapped and bring the king up there
was this outside idea for sure i think tobo's
already in i gotta get back to some air drums
it's getting it's getting close danny
i mean there's a way you can stalemate
here but uh she's going to bring the uh
oh when i first looked at it i thought it
was her move and i thought she
might be about to play king g6
ah that is a stalemate you are right okay it's
over she found it king h5 h1 we're going overtime
dude this is great bog champs is so great eco
still hasn't smiled in a long time it's kind
of there it's it's kind of sit there a smile
nope okay oh thumbs up all right i'm smiling
every time people are like man what do you do
for a living and i say i commentate on chess
we'll be right back
yeah i know i should have taken that pawn i know
i know i should have done that instead of castled
oh god i'm just such an idiot i
guess my brain dude what the heck
ludwig is dm me you got this tower oh god okay
don't be too eager to attack um make sure homes
good before you go to wars okay okay okay thank
you lord thank you got you i got you i got you
tuba i got you tie breaker is a very simple single
game of chess five-minute five-minute chess no
increment whoever wins wins nico has white okay
oh wow chess.com knows how to give the correct
people the correct pieces now that's cool because
feels like that's a new thing they've learned
didn't think they had that technology in the past
like oftentimes they get the wrong colors so good
that the top seed got the right one this time
rayne wilson my name is pronounced ludwig not
ludwig although correctly it is pronounced ludwig
but i'm just not german i'm a [ __ ] white
american who eats mcdonald's on saturdays
ah anyway what's up hess hess is dead to me
i'm a celtics fan he sent me this this morning
i had two celtics tickets in my car and
someone broke in and left three more smfh
you all stay safe like bro
why you gotta do me like that
i lost yesterday oh wait wait wait chess.com it's
actually the perfect time to show you this clip
hold up let's see if i can find it
in time clutch gaming performances
live on air clock winding down here
will he be able to find it surely
great games everyone are you done yeah i gotta
i gotta do the calls okay wait do we have to do
it right now uh i don't think you have to do it
but um i'm gonna do it later i'm gonna run it
now and then there's also the um the pog champs
match oh good look at that good luck good luck
good luck don't get forked right yeah uh so i got
eliminated yesterday oh great games everyone are
you done yeah i got a same shirt this happened
literally two hours ago two [ __ ] hours ago
they says to me good luck like i didn't
get my ass handed to me by in game three
i had like 200 000 people watching it across all
the streams like i thought they wouldn't know i
i tweeted i has i did not tweet i has after
crushing sardosh decisively in a 3-0 victory
stop saying same shirt as if i should change the
shirt from two out i wore it two hours ago it's
i've been live i it's not it's the same day you
don't change shirts dated didn't it's not weird
to wear the same shirt in the same day yeah the
hair is the same that's always the same though
even when you get it cut it's the
same hey [ __ ] you fuckchest.com
let's go tubbo make make sure
you mess up the colors again
oh sorry we're live okay we're back um what we've
got here is a tie break coming up here we've got
uh sudden death with 5.0 not armageddon
anymore levy so you said nico has already
won armageddon match but this is not armageddon
it is just simply 5-0 and we will switch colors
until we have a winner um and yes yes that that i
guess is the main difference in armageddon match
one side has more time and the other side has draw
odds uh but uh yeah i'm just used to calling it
armageddon sudden death sudden death or playoff or
whatever um but it is it is um it is going to be
sudden death meaning the moment you lose you're
out but if it's a draw the games will continue
and uh i i hope we go forever
by the way shout out to the 50
donut we had right there before we came back we
saw you thank you so much so okay nico versus tubo
it's overtime we saw that lud was actually
texting tubbo advice rooting on his man um
blitz i gotta give the nod to nico because she
freaking fast yeah i was gonna say there's no
bonus time and i mean she's gonna go real quick
she's got practice moving pieces in one second
double's gotta always gotta
think he's gotta not get nervous
and i have no idea who gets what color we're
going to find out right now nico's got white
nico's got white okay and uh and we're off to
see the wizard so wow look at her mixing it
up now she's all over the map forget the birds
yeah she gonna play b3 or g3 what's she gonna do
d3 okay okay let's play guess the move with
nico uh you got to say it now because she's
probably already pretty g3 g3 i'll say e3 ether
oh that's a good one i should have said that
so now okay one nothing danny
okay next move is gonna be oh god
h g three h three oh um there we go all
right one one one one all right i think
i think we know the next one danny i
think we know bishop g2 so be too soon
okay she's already pre-moved bishop bishop
no don't you don't dude if you get if
whoever wins this game gets the nikko that
takes some real skill oh if he takes i don't
know what she's going to take back with oh
my god i'm trying to get into nico's head um
he takes if e takes she's gonna say with the e
pawn so i guess you gotta take the other one right
yeah i'll i'll i'll i'll take g takes if
she sticks if you take so it's one one
right now because neither of us guessed f4
tubbo was shook dude tubbo was shook he is
i mean he's too long what okay bishop gt
oh b3 okay nope whoa um knight f3 nope
i didn't realize that we were still uh though we
were still this is too fast pace for me uh pawn
takes pawn she's gonna play oh my god i would
dude i'm so scared i gotta work queen up one no
fast and by the way jokes aside she's up a minute
on the clock this is why i picked her to win this
tiebreaker now she plays knight now of course he
should just shred it open pawn takes pawn she'll
respond to a pawn takes pawn if that happens yeah
well knight d4 would be basically winning for
black i saw someone chat saying explain why black
is winning here white has moved way too many pawns
and not developed pieces and this is a devastating
pin if oh okay he plays bishop before nineteen
was much better she's gonna play bishop e2 don't
take please don't take don't just i think she sees
it rook b1 wow that's you know so she's protecting
the bishop um and she's playing fast right i mean
she's definitely a natural blitz player i will
someone said that wow okay uh i don't know what
she's gonna do she's gonna play uh h3 when
in doubt move upon oh i was gonna say that
but then i was like no way move that is a good
move yeah the biggest user good i was gonna say
tuple's been very trade averse yeah and he
might not take and he might hang his bishop
she's gonna take the bishop hopefully
she might take the night nope
she took the knight double take you should
we choose the move niko unpin your knight
oh god okay it's good good good
he's got oh now if he takes
he hangs his queen okay he's gonna
say chances tobo plays he takes f4
he can't i can't watch they play it they
okay no knight d4 okay bishop takes good
she can't castle though she can't count
this is a this is a real problem and you're
going to be the best bishop of all timelines
you know if double plays pawn c five pawn
b6 he gets the legendary connect five
that's pretty like that that's pretty decisive
h3 was a good move by nico i think that
again she's slowed down a little bit with
the time on the clock and so if she can
get out of the bind she's in somehow
very tricky this is a horn sure but
still think that remember there's no
increment coming no help coming so
tubo has got to do something before it's too
late okay she's gonna take back yeah he's got
two minutes to break through a completely
locked structure this is not easy at all
yeah i mean the ways to do it
you've got to find something with
okay g5 is one crazy idea but even even c6 and
d5 gotta open up lines fast she's thinking about
what you're thinking about like this is a
snap take moment kind of just don't even
i think she's just trying
to make this dramatic for us
it's crazy because the best move here for black
is probably some wild thing like d5 or b5 or c6
and d5 or b5 just that's not bad but that's not
gonna open the position yeah it's not a bad move
but again you're down a whole minute on the clock
eco should just shuffle oh that opens up this idea
yes this is getting well i would just
trade the queen and now it's a very
low chance that you get checkmated it's a
high chance you might blunder a rook but
this is objectively even even if
this were just two strong players
playing this is very close to a draw with
obstacle bishops yeah she's gotta just not
i'm gonna say like she just has to not play
e5 that's all yeah just don't play e5 like
don't don't keep one yep it's the art of doing
nothing in chess the art of doing nothing but
now she has a lot of play she's going to get
rook a1 maybe e5 and maybe bishop takes rook
yeah okay now just run your king to safety over
here i think she's put herself in a really good
spot because she played fast her her greatest
skill really in terms of the disparity between her
and her opponents has been how quickly she's done
things and it's really going to pay off in blitz
will she remember son oh this is so wow a5
changes though oh she's played e5 it's the
oh danny i'm going crazy
but rook takes wasn't played but now tubbo's
speeding up yeah he's also speeding up that's
the thing he's realized that he don't want
to lose on time he's only 20 seconds away
now she might freeze up from nerves look at this
king oh my god these ships this is crazy danny
no back up uh oh she might get made it
she might get made it in the middle of
the board something completely insane yeah
like one of those accidental checkmates
put your king on the wrong square come on
give her give a check give a check or get
that other rook in the game tubbo that now's not
the time to tank buddy that's a great move that's
a great move if he sees rookie three especially
to follow it don't go rookie one just don't think
here comes d3 he plays it without having
to be asked this is moving too quickly
oh g-flat what a save don't
take it oh that's a good move
that too putting on the uh check he's
still he's still blabbering away over there
he's got to not hang his rook sometimes you have
this blind spot king attacks rook and then king
takes rook and you just forget don't don't
forget about that 15 seconds the difference
on time oh it might happen yeah he might forget
and push his spot losing himself into the dancing
this is insane danny oh geez on the bishop
oh he finds it it finds oh but now now now the
pass pawn now dude this could backfire the b-pawn
okay what a move although if she sees b8 as an
x-ray tactic that would just be bananas i think
she might just push because like what else
do you do okay she goes up now he oh that's
a great move and that would be six oh my gosh
great technique with no time only 40 seconds
this is insane 50 uh i mean five seconds is the
difference takes takes v7 first now he can take b5
and there's no back rank danny the the
most important thing there's no background
checkmate but there is enough material on
the board that either player could still flag
the fact that he's under 30 seconds this is gonna
oh man forget the eval bar it's all that matters
is the time off the board neither player is
gonna mate in this amount of time left levy
this is gonna i think she's gonna win on the
clock i'm sorry but that's what's gonna happen
yeah if you're playing with black here in
this and and and you're in a game it's not
about mates about taking all the pieces off the
board without rook training yeah yes absolutely
oh he's got the pawn that's good yeah but now
get the not enough time and look at her she's
practically pre-moving yeah the problem is that
if are they going to repeat oh they're going to i
thought we were about to see a repeat we might
see it how crazy would that be five seconds
she's pre-moving moving nico removing
her way to the championship match
in the consolation bracket this is crazy that's
how you get it done boys right there you pretty
move your way all the way to victory wow
and she smiled someone clip it fast enough
no 90 seconds
that's heartbreaking oh man that's heartbreaking
but that's chess baby that's winner take all wow
heartbreaking for tubbo we have a a battle of
i mean opposites in terms of style and approach
in many ways between michelle carrey and uh and
uh nico in the final i don't even know how to
make sense of what we just saw but i do know we're
going to talk to the players in just a few moments
so don't go anywhere interviews with nico and tubo
pogchamps3 presented by grip6 in just a moment
interview i would love to
listen to their interview
and now we know it's an all girls final oh girls
final let me invite you to your board was it this
yeah it's this game why is it why is it saying
one zero on chess.com oh one zero okay i thought
it said zero one okay i can't read my country i
was like how did black win when black lost on time
i think we're on chess.com are we are we
i heard us on the stream hello everybody
this is bakchio's finalists misha
curry we've been watching consolation
the consolation it's still a final michelle you
made it and now we know your opponent we've been
watching the match between toppo and nico um i'm
very biased that i've been rooting for an august
final because i've been working both with nico and
michelle and now the two of you will play against
each other michelle your first thoughts about what
has just happened in the tiebreaker and it was so
awesome niko played so fast it was really exciting
to watch and i'm really really excited and honored
to play her tomorrow it's gonna be awesome and
you can share with the rest of the viewers on
chess.com as well that you have actually played
a mini match against nico a few weeks ago i did
i did at the sort of the beginning of this journey
and um she's very good it is it was very intense
it was a training much set up by the botus sister
shout out to alexandre nandra for the initiative
because they organized couple of training matches
for you guys for the punctures participants and
i thought that was a very very useful training
additional training for you to be in a competitive
tournament situation not just play against viewers
or random people but also to to have the same form
at the same time control in a match situation
so that was one one i believe the training match
and there the tie breaker was just a puzzle
solving session puzzle rush which destroyed me
in the puzzle right you weren't familiar with that
for a tie breaker and and you were very nervous
that training match you had against nico you
were really nervous in both games you have gone
you have come so far since you have improved
so much more in terms of how you deal with
pressure and how how to turn that nervousness
into being excited about oh this is a challenge
this is great i'm gonna i'm gonna put
out my put myself out there i'm gonna
try my best i'm gonna do my best and we will
see what happens because you've been doing
really well since michelle this yesterday's
matches double win for michelle double win
i don't know how long oh that we have 50 seconds
to the interview i was gonna invite you to
an analysis board or maybe
the one we had i could just
change um let me set up their game and
we can quickly open it to for ourselves
basically what nico missed if you see the position
michelle the analysis what we had earlier if you
go back to that same one yeah these dot com slash
live yeah do you still have can you reinvite me
oh sure yeah sorry no worries no worries i
forgot that it might it might not be there
and we are back here with our final interview of
the day we've got tubbo and nico nico it took it
took three games but you finally smiled at the
end of the last game there take us through take
us through your thought process and how were you
nervous were you just stone cold killer focused
what was going on in your head uh all all i've
heard up until this match i was that tower was
temple was really good and i was like oh my god
like he's gonna beat me like i already came in
here with the mentality to get like stomped
on but i was like wait wait i actually think
i possibly might have a chance so you know i've
regardless i stayed hopeful but nonetheless like
i was very sweaty because he was playing he
was like predicting my moves pretty well and
i was like oh my god like i can't believe
he's like predicting every one of my moves
but um but yeah it was definitely like
a a challenge i would say so i it was it
was pretty it was pretty good i was also i i'm
also dealing with a huge headache right now but
i've made it through well then wait way to
go way to push through it i know this didn't
go no no no i i i think i need to drink some
water after this i think i'm just dehydrated
how are you feeling right now i know it didn't
go how you wanted but it was as close as it could
possibly get it was a great time it was very very
close oh man the time out at the end i was trying
to check as many times as i could as fast as
i could i didn't know it was just not enough
time i guards down at the clock and saw there
was three seconds left and i was like uh-oh
i would do you play blitz a lot like five
minutes because i know for this it's all
mostly rapid and practice generally we say
rap do you play like three or five at all
i played one minute quite a
lot just on my phone in bed
that's what i have same yeah and danny too i think
i think that's actually that's pretty much too um
but uh yeah well tobo you've now played in you
you've had a lot of chess right you played block
champs you played in pog champs here what has been
your experience overall how do you feel about your
chest in terms of where you were to where you've
come and did you have a good time it's got it's
got a lot more i've got i feel like i've got
a lot better but i'm not sure because when i
started i was a little bit confused about all the
strategies and all the weird names and i think
i've kind of got the weird names in the bag now
or the ones that i know of anyway yeah i think uh
what is the percent balance when you're playing
in these events that you have to entertain a
massive community of supporters and also like
focus because it feels like no i'd say it's like
60 40. yeah it's i was gonna say it feels like
a lot i feel like if you get to play off stream
and just grind a little bit i think i think
your focus is there because you definitely
you know you you catch on you plan things out
well but you do have a pretty big responsibility
there as well um danny i was gonna ask nico uh
nico i feel like danny and i talked about this
the final of the consolation with you and
michelle it's like polar opposite styles right so
you are fast and when the game opens up you
find like the tactics that become available
michelle is very slow and methodical so how
have you scouted her out as an opponent at all
and like what do you think uh what do you think
that final is gonna be like for you i actually
have played against michelle and and
this is very true like she's very um
methodical i i i don't know how it's going to
play out i mean and the the tactics i use with
with chubbo were like i tried because i feel like
i don't know maybe if this is not true or maybe it
is but i feel like he already knew what my opening
was so i was trying to see if i could throw him
off and see like what is she doing or like is so
that that's kind of like the tactic that i try
to use because it's like i don't i haven't had
time to like learn other openings because i was
moving and then the storm and everything so i was
trying to like just juke my opponents if i could
but uh but yeah i like going fast so not nothing's
gonna change there when i go up against michelle
well it obviously makes you super dangerous if we
get to a tie break as we know it and nico you you
know we said in the beginning you were you were
streaming chess before chess was cool long ago
before the first pog champs now that you're moving
into the final of the consolation is it is it
cool for you that given that chess was one of the
first things you were you were streaming um before
it was as popular as it's been as it's been now
and um what would it mean to you to win tomorrow
um it would be actually a lot i feel like when i
first started playing chess there was like this
um elitist kind of vibe over the chess community
like you know you had to be like fide master grand
master super saiyan power 3000 elo but now like
um i feel it's a lot more chill and i feel like it
could show that other content creators could also
uh play chess and have fun and get better and be
good uh including myself so um i think that that
is kind of what i'm hoping to approve tomorrow by
winning cool all set um it was very funny i'm
gonna miss the eardrums bro i'm not gonna lie
i'm gonna miss the eardrums a lot oh man without
attraction the eardrums no everything was man uh
all the music i mean it's just cool i think it's
cool to see so many different people from so
many different categories with so it's where are
the eardrums oh uh you know one last time tubbo
you just do that when you're like when you're
like in the in the in the game and like in the
good song
well tubby you are a lot of fun to watch seriously
and uh we we it's been awesome having you we hope
to maybe see you again in future yes kind of kind
of shows 100 percent i agree with levy i think
i think you you entertain well and we definitely
get this vibe that if there was a little bit of
a calmer kind of chill or chest focus stream
it's really hard to say what your what your
ceiling might be because you know you do a lot of
things really well and it's been awesome to watch
oh thank you man i will enjoy the rest of your
weekend nico you got it you now have a date
tomorrow on sunday we know what you're doing with
your weekend right you got pog champs and uh we'll
see you at 12 pacific tomorrow for your battle
versus michelle thank you and that gg tubo it was
really good playing with you it was very fun thank
you for the games thanks guys guys ggs right right
well there you have it the bracket is
filled levy michelle and nico in the final
this is uh this is awesome man i don't know if you
know the uh the story of michelle in this event
uh i think you do the full story right like it's
uh yeah yeah you just i got an email one day from
the host of challenge accepted and we were talking
chess we like spoke on the phone and then she was
like what would be a good final goal and i was
like we got this little thing coming up called
pogchamp she's like what's that i was like let
me tell you about pogchamps michelle and this was
literally the dream because we knew that the
stack feel of the championship bracket would
be too difficult but this is it danny this
might be the culmination of our whole project
seriously and and we know that michelle is going
to put together an amazing whatever it is what do
we call what she does it's challenge accepted
it's a documentary style kind of breakdown of
of her experiences she commits to specific tasks
and goals and tries to master them so if you don't
know her content you should definitely just google
michelle carey check out her youtube channel it's
really cool stuff and yeah i think whether she
wins or loses tomorrow she made it to the finals
so i feel like it almost it almost doesn't matter
it's almost a win for her channel and content as
far as the story of committing to something like
a pog champs event and trying to win it and maybe
she'll go all the way by the way we will also have
the championship match right after that of course
and i'm also being updated now so you know that it
will actually be 1 20 pacific so it does not start
at noon tomorrow the consolation match between
nico and michelle starts at 1 20 pacific time and
then the championship will take place at 2 40 p.m
pacific time obviously give or take a few minutes
here and there as we do on these things when you
know you get overtime or you get other stuff so
levy this has been a lot of fun we got to do this
more often this whole thing you know this this
relationship it there's something here i agree uh
and and we showed up matching i didn't know you
were going to wear that and uh is that wearing
bright salmon is that a salmon color that's
what is i don't think you're supposed to
pronounce the l in that word but i i just
really like pink hoodies so i always wore blue
and black my whole life and gray uh and then um
now recently i was like you know what i'm bored
so i upgraded to maroon i got purple i got pink
i wear you know they the thing about being
a streamer danny we'll say it's a bubble gum
color everybody sees your sh your
clothes every day when you stream so
like i got to bring bright colors to the table
because i'm going to run out of it yeah so
well um anyway it's been awesome i will be back
tomorrow with icaro for the fans that are still
here with us make sure you tune in it will be
the championship battles for both the consolation
and the championship bracket respectively so shout
out again to everyone who's been here thank you so
much for the community i'm hoping that we'll reach
our our goals tomorrow and and continue to do all
the things we can to make sure these charities
get the support they deserve the crew here
international master levy
rosman high five that's me
oh oh sorry i i was looking at my camera because
you know we got to be my bad i didn't mean to wait
i got you i got you all right ready yeah what
we did uh oh okay oh one more time all right
ready go bam all right i felt that danny
i felt that thanks for being here everyone
and uh we will see you tomorrow for
more pogchamps 3 presented by grip6
so
three two one
three two one here we go
let's go
get out check it out